why not
guidely starting we'll talk about dirty
feet
this show is presented by on it
the church what's happening now is all
brought to you by cso
s-e-e-s-o
dot com go to cso.com for bingeable
comedy anytime anywhere and our
listeners get your first two months for
free when you enter promo code joey at
checkout you can take those with you
mediocre weed for the
think one of garage thank you show is
also brought to you by helix sleep where
you can buy mattresses online customized
for you for hundreds of dollars instead
of thousands go to helixsleep.com joey
to get 50 off of your order
helixsleep.com joey and the show is
brought to you by mvmt watches
go to
mvmtwatches.com church right now to get
15 off of their amazing stylish watches
i have mine it's black on black i love
it looking at it right now it's
beautiful mvmtwatches.com
church to get 15 off with free shipping
and free returns
[Music]
kick that [ __ ] muley it's monday
night [ __ ]
november 14th [ __ ]
four days away
from my anniversary kidnapping ken bella
29 years yeah
here we go i'll be in houston texas
the church of what's happening now
greg fitzsimmons
my goomba of death lisa
kick that mule league i don't hear it
kick it you're playing games with me
[Music]
take that [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
speaking of 30 feet turn that [ __ ] off
before we jump join the podcast
i was telling uh i don't want to sound
like trump jr here but i was telling
because i don't even know what sex this
is now this word has me all scared yeah
you got to be careful you got to be
careful but the problem was i'm on the
[ __ ] plane the other day i'm on
jetblue like a doctor
and i'm watching the fight it's on fx
and i like amy adams that's her name
maybe adams i think amy adams is
beautiful amy adams looks like every
irish girl i dated from
the seventh grade to the 11th to you
know and we held hands there was no sex
in those days i didn't have the [ __ ]
heart i would go for a tit from time to
time in the winter time right but
there's something about them being irish
that just there was this girl colleen
that had that same color hair yeah was
it chili that's saint michael's
shoestring you told me about that she
used to rock my [ __ ] world tell me
about this you know then i switch i jump
i jump book
and i start dating this other girl kathy
we were also irish oh
beautiful we were
big cheeks we used to [ __ ] run
together at night and one night we just
started swapping spitting we'd hold
hands and then walk home like nothing
happened no sex was involved
then i dated one of her friends for a
while
i don't want to say their names because
people from the area listen to this [ __ ]
and oh i love him love him but there's
one scene where uh what's his name the
[ __ ] dude
marky wahlberg marky wahlberg is is
about to have sex with her and she's got
a bra on and panties and you can see
that the panties smell like you know
when you look at panties and they have
like little skid marks in the back
that [ __ ] turns me on too
right it's like a shadow she's not the
perfect woman in the world she's just
got a face that could just stop you in
your tracks but her body is not like a
super body but when she falls onto the
bed
her feet except for the arches are just
covered black
and let me tell you something my dick
almost blew up on the plane okay
if the stew this was cute i would ask
them for a hand job
and that's a jet blue stone that's a jet
blue that's [ __ ] that's not a good
let me tell you something i i love women
i love irish women yeah i was thinking
about how my daughter has that color
hair now yeah like my my wife is [ __ ]
strawberry
and my daughter's got it now and it's
everything i ever wanted you know i'm
saying like uh it's so weird how it hits
home now it came to haunt me what i
really loved came back to [ __ ] haunt
me you know
i love all that dirty irish [ __ ] yeah
feet i love women i love all that that
she's a little cellulite a little bit
she's got amy adam's got a little mole
on the side she even had a little bit of
a gut at the bar when she did a shot
oh
sends me over the [ __ ] absolutely i i
missed almost east ghostwoman like i
missed them actually i'm not around a
lot of east coast women out here like
vicky pezza like i love vicky pezza
because she like the woman at the shows
were just yelling at their boyfriends
and it was like i almost missed it the
girls at foxwoods were [ __ ] banging
yeah i mean banging from a to z those
guys i gotta hand it to anybody who
showed up at fox woods or boy the
[ __ ] will but you brought some
[ __ ] heat jack yeah they brought
heavy artillery out there you didn't
show up with no quincy [ __ ]
you showed up
you didn't show up with those shipyard
[ __ ] yeah they stopped and that's how
you're working there's like three or
four hot ones up in quincy the rocky
world they don't even know how hot they
are yeah like uh the chick that played
the the town what was that movie with oh
um
okay the blake lively that broad played
it to the [ __ ] hilton
just a dirty irish girl the ball that
goes out every night for a good time i
love those girls yeah
the only makeup is just something
you're not gonna [ __ ] tell them not
to go out every night yeah that's going
to stop right there cause they'll knock
the [ __ ] out of you you just take them
home three nights a week and you have a
great time with them they puke
they always puke after you give them a
stabbing right
and you gotta kiss them and [ __ ] you
don't give a [ __ ] by that point
you did what you had to do and [ __ ] they
wake up what happened i don't know what
happened
they wake up you're down at the bottom
of the bed licking their dirty feet oh
loving every [ __ ] minute i don't like
toes i don't lick toes that's disgusting
and but i like the dirty feet but once
we get in the bed you got to wash those
hoses
i don't i can't have those dirty hooves
on my bed do you wash their feet i got a
[ __ ] no no no what am i jesus jesus
i got a fungi tone myself i'm walking
around with duct tape on it
[ __ ] sometimes i get radio waves i'm
like a [ __ ] antenna now with my
little fun guy [ __ ] though gotta get
those those sneakers with the toes cut
out
this fungi toe is killing me because
like for six months i'll just throb at
night the fungi comes alive it hurts
yeah i thought it was just growing again
this weekend i go in the tub and i just
sit there for like i only do it in
hotels i bring the heavy-duty artillery
to the hotels and [ __ ] the the
industrial nail cutters yeah and the
[ __ ] you clean the phone
so i go in the tub i soak that [ __ ] i
cut those nails and i take them and i
sniff them real good
do you save it for after the show i
leave them for the mate yeah i put a 20
right on top there you go have a party
[ __ ] sucker she comes in the room she
listens to couch there's a thousand
little [ __ ] fungi nails everywhere
all different colors green purple
they're like the gay flag
they cut holes in the [ __ ] cushions
jesus sharp oh my god sometimes i cut
him and poke my wife with them i was
telling him i was just poking and she go
what the [ __ ] is that it's a guy now
keep it up
there's like a snake tooth
she's gonna get like an infection
i'll take this to a concert i'll stab
like 18 people
16 will start scratching with 10 minutes
that's what i should do take a fungi
nail
and do a show it's me stabbing people
with my fungi now
can i stab you with my phone right now
get someone to eat oh that's it i'm
gonna let them
grow sell it after the show i used to
date this girl she grew up she used to
grew up in a cult
and one of the jobs she had to do was
cut the [ __ ] masters toenails
and like what do you mean she goes they
grew over his toe
so once a week we'd have to go upstairs
he weighed like 500 pounds
they all had to suck his dick no [ __ ] he
[ __ ] all their moms it's a horrible
how old was she
14.
yeah she basically grew up in that
[ __ ] cult and she still talks to her
parents
i would [ __ ] chip in with my brothers
and have them hit by a truck yeah right
yeah i'm saying you dirty [ __ ]
you want to be freaks and move into a
cult do it on your own time leave people
my aunt
who goes to church on sundays yeah
you're gonna take me with you to some
fat [ __ ] house yeah he's gonna [ __ ] us
all in the ass
and the father's sleeping at night while
everybody's getting [ __ ] including his
wife because they had seven kids but
three of them belong to the cult leader
oh no but they took them with them and
sold them as their own and when you see
the whole family together sold them like
you know they sold them the story that
they were parents you're crazy or your
dad
so four kids have a lot of teeth
and the other three kids are just
sitting there [ __ ] with regular
[ __ ] smiles you know what i'm saying
and nobody's smiling everybody's
frowning yeah because everybody's
confused why does he have blonde hair
what a shame in this country oh my god
the cults
it's part of it seems appealing to me at
this point you know
to start a cult
i just need to come up with some crazy
[ __ ] you know like i think i i think i
would run a good cult
what qualifies it as a cult
you can't leave okay oh [ __ ] you can't
oh no yeah no you gotta stick around but
i think that uh
i think i wouldn't [ __ ] the girls i'd
let everybody get laid you know and i
think we'd raise some money
but uh
i wouldn't hog it spread it around let
everybody have some fun but get a
[ __ ] get some land build some cabins
a lot of nudity good music
a lot of doors
the doors the doors that's what we had
on tonight la woman what a phenomenal
house great album that really is a good
[ __ ] album man yeah they produce good
albums in the studio let me tell you
something
growing up that album irritated me to no
end
my mom wouldn't listen to the whole
album she just listened to l.a woman
over
and over and over l.a woman is how i
learned how to speak spanish english in
a way oh yeah because she played make me
dance
for the other women in the room right
they play cards and [ __ ] and my mom
would pull out l.a that sounds like a
cult but it wasn't the cult it was a
bunch of crazy cuban women playing cards
and snorting blowing in the 70s
and uh
it's crazy how when i was 13 i picked up
the album on my own
and i would play it my mom was like i
thought you didn't like this [ __ ] like
oh no i hated it because you tell me how
hot jim morrison was yeah when you
[ __ ] five you don't want to be here
by the hot guy
and my mom would say someday i'm going
to meet jim morrison and just eat them
yeah spanish she would say milo may
compile and i would go what the [ __ ] are
you talking about wow my you know cuban
women loved
steve mcqueen
and jim morrison they loved rock cuts
until they found out he was gay yeah not
eating 85 they knew in the 60s rock was
gay in the 50s when he would go to cuba
that's where he would go to escape to be
gay
because you could be gay in cuba in the
50s you were a
celebrity so i could bring
joe fagg as my assistant yeah get two
rooms but he's not there to sleep in
that room he's over in the room with me
rubbing my [ __ ] fungi toenail and
sucking my toe and sucking my balls and
you know what i'm saying his tongue
would be my bidet yeah yeah and he's
making eye contact yeah
you know that's how rock hudson i mean
when i was a kid my mom used to always
tell me that that rock hudson was gay
yeah and i would go [ __ ] how do you
know that and when i got older like two
years before she died
she goes all the way now i'm gonna tell
you
whenever rock hudson came to town it was
a big deal so i was a young girl we'd
all go down there and wait for him he
would stay locked up with the guy all
weekend
who wouldn't who would go to the cube
but not go out yeah that's why you went
to cuba to see the [ __ ] dancing and
the spanish women and the [ __ ]
mulattas dancing and [ __ ] benny
murray singing and you gamble
he wouldn't leave the [ __ ] hotel room
yeah and i would look at my mom and go
you know what you're [ __ ] crazy
you're crazy
she dies six years later he's got aids
yeah and i'm like [ __ ] lady he was
telling me the truth yeah because when
they were little girls it was like when
michael jackson went to london and hung
his kid outside the window there was 2
000 people waiting same thing [ __ ]
rock hudson
you're a cuban girl you're [ __ ] 12 13
years old
and rock hudson the biggest [ __ ] star
in american peliculas is coming to
[ __ ] cuba what's cuba the size of
bayonne yeah everybody knows if you're
coming once you land at the airport
you know sinatra's in town you knew yeah
so you went down there that's what
happened to the bay of pigs you guys
figured it out
who knows yeah
what's up lee
how you feeling dog i'm feeling we went
to legal seafood like 18 times oh you
know what i was gonna i want to thank
legal seafoods for [ __ ] taking good
care of me
good oh okay uh that was actually one of
my favorite parts not just legal
seafoods bill the the bartender i meant
like i meant i'm not even a drinker but
i used my dad always used to take me to
the bar we always used to eat at this
bar sushi bar any bar and i miss guys
like bill
who just like have like a regular
conversation we we eat up bars a lot bro
he came to our table when we didn't sit
at the bar like he became
our friend i met some great people in
boston the the star of my world
was the hotel manager margaret the
restaurant manager yeah
she was as beautiful as she was smart
and [ __ ]
she was 24 years old she started there
as a bus girl boston accent
yeah dirty girl yeah dirty irish girl
but beautiful boyfriend you know just
set one of those girls that you look at
and she'll be married in three years
we just spoke about the internet
and her other business
was the internet that's what she really
wanted that's what she went to college
for she was trying to sell products on
there
and we just spoke about that but both
conversations left me [ __ ]
like wow you know finally you meet
somebody who's dynamite then the bar
bill
from the [ __ ] first day i got there
my name is bill who [ __ ] introduces
himself anymore oh you mean he was
behind the bar he was behind the bar
right and he came right over gave me a
menu put his hand up
[ __ ] guys what six four
265
hands that'll [ __ ] crush your head
bald old yeah you know you don't need
much all he needs is one good [ __ ]
shot to your head and you're hearing
you're hearing [ __ ] a boston red sox
game and it's [ __ ] january and you
got like i had to play this big puppy
and he came over and i said to him what
do you think and he goes try this this
this this you know i tried one of the
things he recommended
i drank iced teas that was the i got off
the plane and went right to legal
seafood you know me i don't [ __ ] around
right you gotta get get as many meals
you can you gotta get the meals i rolled
the joint and [ __ ] uh you take a walk
i found a place to smoke i smoked
backwards
then i realized they didn't give a [ __ ]
because it was legal yeah
and then i walked into legal seafood
wreaking of marijuana reeking went right
to the bar no hello to the hostess
nothing
and i blasted out something i forget
what i ate the first day old muscles
i had muscles and clam chowder just by
yourself sitting at the bar solo like a
doctor i came out of this [ __ ]
solo
i went out i went upstairs 10 o'clock i
asked bill bill what time you closed he
goes 11. i'll see you around 10.
i took a shower i tried to write some
jokes i watched some tv 10 o'clock
another joint pew right downstairs
because you came back
i got back that night i ate clams on a
half shell like a doctor wow and crab
cake with a salad
the next day i had breakfast at the
hotel ah mensa molt
but for lunch you know where i was gonna
be legal seafood [ __ ] yeah yeah i think
we went there for late dinner yeah
absolutely we went there after the
[ __ ] wheelchair like doctors come on
that place isn't cheap either no no but
i said listen man
i didn't get sick i could trust him
the day i went and met lee and his mom
for lunch which would made my [ __ ]
whole weekend has you met her before
never was she i didn't know what to
expect i expected something completely
different than what i meant yeah first
of all just the fact that my mom was
dead dirty something he is last week
just the fact that he let me meet his
mom
knowing how crazy he meant the world to
me yeah i was expecting an attorney
i was expecting a woman with the
temperament
uh forgive the english of a jewish
attorney yeah single divorced
60s
she's already seen it all yeah you know
what i'm saying that's what i expected i
ended up sitting next to
uh the sweetest woman i've met in the
years really and i could tell she was
lonely i could tell she wants to leave
back so now i'm guilty
because you and i if my mom was alive i
live around the corner i'd be rubbing
her feet and breaking her balls and
making me cook right or wrong okay if i
had a chance to be with my mother again
i would dump my girlfriend
not worth the aggravation i'd throw my
mom eight what's the what's the mortgage
here mom 12 here's nine
let me live downstairs like a doctor
which means you know what a doctor means
dog means when you wake up you know you
wake up to
mom with bacon yeah two eggs toast just
how you like it
drink the coffee greg before it gets
cold and she's standing there at the pot
right there right there
as you're pissing
she's telling you about the weather and
what happened and what what avenue to
take cause it's busy and mr mailman got
cancer
you can jerk off in the bathroom nobody
bothers you she's just happy that yeah
at that age that gets to a point with
mom and dad where they don't give a [ __ ]
they're just happy that you're there and
you're having a great time you don't
don't you know what you can't bring
women there and you can't disrespect
them and get high yes i got to give them
that who gives a [ __ ] i'll take a walk
how old am i you know what i'm saying
yeah but think about if i because i
haven't had a mom in 30 years so when
lee goes yeah she's like why are you
[ __ ] kidding me
all these [ __ ] pay rent how long you
been gone uh
well i was i've been here almost six and
then i was gone for four of college so
pretty much ten yeah yeah you're ready
to head back home
you know i'm saying mom what's the
mortgage here what do you need a month
to make you happy here you go yeah i'm
taking the basement off i'm redoing the
basement disco ball
they don't give a [ __ ] jack
when you walk in at 501 they're at the
door
with dinner slippers yeah ready for you
at attention again with all the details
and there's always something in the
fridge
hard-boiled eggs yeah always homemade
homemade cake yeah there's a homemade
cake
where you gonna go you put weights
downstairs right a punching bag
you get elliptical you don't go nowhere
you go out get a job just minimally yeah
that's it mom what do we need here to
make it happen so what i get my dick
sucked for massage parlor once a week i
got the fungi nail
watch my nut 1500 i work at the deli
just to live at hope
you're spending half your paycheck on a
[ __ ] yeah right when you live with
mom yeah if you live with mom you're a
widow yeah you know you go somewhere to
get your dick sucked and your balls late
you go somewhere filthy because that's
what balance out living with mom you
know what i'm saying anybody who lives a
mom has like a girlfriend but they do
something filthy yeah because that makes
you feel normal where you been greg my i
can't tell you
yeah
you don't want to know
and the thought of living with my mom
like
it wasn't her but i just i i wanted to
get out at 18. and now i don't i don't
want to live with her but like i'm only
within like 20 minutes i'll tell you
what three months ain't bad with mom
oh yeah i could do three months yeah if
i had to you tell the girlfriend you're
getting your head together not to call
for three listen don't call for three
months i'm getting my head together
i got somebody taking care of you
you come back your toenails are clipped
oh [ __ ] smiling oh they put they rub
apple cider on your toe and [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying they put that
exorcist acid on your toenails
moms don't do anything they'll pop the
pimples on your back right
don't do anything i got a blackhead
right under my nut sack
they put the glasses on with the light
over it and [ __ ] don't get that
blackhead
i used to jerk off on my t-shirts and i
thought years later about how you know
how they were all clumped together you
ever come on a t-shirt and it just saw
sticks to itself when i was younger
anyway and then i think about uh my mom
would have to see that [ __ ] she'd wash
it you know think about what moms do for
you no but i see that's where you trick
them you gotta blow your nose so now
they don't really know it's i blow my
nose and everything underwear
dirty socks
but that wouldn't be true that's my one
for my my mom no why are you blowing
your nose in your shirts because i just
it's right here and i don't want to
[ __ ] how many trees can we kill how
many trees can we kill everything about
trees mom
you're the one that's up here they vote
for clinton now you don't give a [ __ ]
about trees
jerking off is green you got to keep it
green
i don't know i used to jerk off on
something when i was disgusting i'd jerk
off on a shirt and put it on like i'm
one of those yeah you unfold that
[ __ ] yeah
that's touch
looks like a tie-dye
it looks like somebody shot it with
something hard like
you need to clarify what you just said
it sounds like you just like laid your
shirt on your bed jerked off on it no no
sometimes no see i told i told you i'm
uncircumcised so i always got a
three-minute
pause because i just hold on to the top
of the turtleneck why and it blows up
like a snake
from the [ __ ] [ __ ] and that gives me
like this shut the [ __ ] up yeah you
didn't know that dog
you didn't know that
i'm uncircumcised
so when i feel myself when i whack off
by myself i just hold on to the top and
it gives me like i sit there for a
minute or two and think what i want to
do i look around
it fills up like a [ __ ] like a back
of a cobra like it fills up
and i go to the toilet and just pull the
skin back and it comes out like a
[ __ ] burp like a boop it just comes
out this whole one whole thing i take
toilet paper i wipe off the helmet i
take a quick piss and it's over that's
it nobody gets that feeling sir and
there's no witnesses he's on his way to
the top
you got a name for that move no it's
called the joey diaz i just hold on to
the top and it swells up i hold on to
the uncircumcised
and it swells up like it's choking i've
held it for five six minutes sometimes
why don't you let it go because what
what then do what stain something i
leave witnesses so you you can enjoy it
holding onto it i don't enjoy it but i
gotta come on something i gotta bend
over and get a sock i can just hold it
in two minutes once [ __ ] i find out
whether lenny briscoe's fired or not
i can go over and unleash the [ __ ]
dragon juice
this is a great podcast on a monday
night this is a great way to start your
week i'm sorry about it went to this
topic i thought you knew i said it on
the right i had no idea i never heard
that before oh i've been doing that
since day one
it gives you like a little time
sometimes you just whack off and you
come wherever you want i think there's
some karma suture thing about grabbing
the base or like tantric is that tantric
when you grab the base i watched listen
but it's before you come and it stops
you from coming years ago when i used to
do blow one of those channels
used to have late night two indians
[ __ ]
like a bunch of indian women [ __ ]
they were hot
like middle eastern indians yeah like
the ones in 7-eleven but they were doing
uh
they were doing sex acts and it was
called kamasutra yeah that was the name
of the show
i don't know this uh felicia used to
date a guy that was into kamasutra
and she said he'd [ __ ] never come
yeah but he do that one night she came
18 times he didn't come one time yeah
i don't know yeah
about that stuff that sounds like you're
a caddy you're not playing yeah like you
can't come but i see a lot of hindus
yeah you're saying it don't work yeah
kamasutra don't work i see a lot of
hindus yeah i think the conversation is
for making more hindus no because you're
not supposed to come yeah you're not
supposed to come i get listen i don't
know don't quote me on this i don't know
i'm smoking dope and eating edibles what
the [ __ ] do i know i'm just a fat [ __ ]
who's uninformed it's not like i'm
sitting here with a computer and [ __ ]
hindus and uh
kamasutra it's good to see you doug
always a pleasure to see you man yeah
you came in looking like i stole your
lunch box i know i'm like what the [ __ ]
it's over that's it
you know
uh
we're living in weird times if you
haven't opened your eyes the last 10
years has been
rough on a lot of people we were just
talking about the film industry
doug if i was still shooting [ __ ] look
i got a call the other day
for a friend i forget what the [ __ ] the
kid's name is i did a shitty movie with
him once and he blew up
this dude blew the [ __ ] up he did those
clint eastwood movies and i just went to
see the one about the pilot
sully yeah and he had a three-minute
role in that i don't give a [ __ ] it was
three minutes or not i wasn't on that
[ __ ] movie
so i gotta call friday he wants me to do
his uh
web series you know and i go okay i
would i'm [ __ ] out of lu lombardi in
him yeah i'm like [ __ ] yeah lulumbardi
was the guy who played the cop
to big [ __ ] and the sopranos that
always tormented him yeah of course
great guy great [ __ ] guy i know from
auditions he came to come to the comedy
store it'd be great but it's a digital
sag yeah it pays a yardstick yeah right
seriously yeah you do know this i'm not
joking no [ __ ]
a hundred hours a day
really i'd love to do it but i'd have to
cancel the pocket no no
i'm figuring it's a yardstick what's
digital seven minutes
you do a take another take and you go
home yeah
two two eleven
damn for how many days
just one 400 bucks a yard stick [ __ ]
you know we were talking about acting
how it used to affect
our income i barely make level two
insurance brother
and three quarters of it to be honest is
on residuals and a half of that is the
longest yard in spider-man 2.
the longest yard has been keeping me in
pork chops that is the longest yard
yeah it's the longest yard it's
stretched out
and they play it no football season
football season thanksgiving eight
o'clock on cbs i just got that check two
weeks ago like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] nice like you know you sit there
that's what's keeping me in pork chops
but the old see it wasn't
i never made money acting like people
spoke about
like i always got the [ __ ] under the
stick i'm not complaining but i tell you
where my forte was
when i first got here i got into
co-stars
and one day somebody made a mistake and
paid me the wrong rate
and that became my raid
[Music]
so i would go in for every co-star in
the beginning and they would [ __ ] their
pants
but i was so bad ass in the auditions
that they'd have to [ __ ] give it to
me yeah i learned that i got to go in
there and that's my value now
i got to go in there like
my guest star role number wasn't good at
that time i wasn't booking guest stars i
had never booked a guest stop
but that disappeared lisa those days
disappeared
in those days i'd get calls from greg
going joey what are you doing tomorrow
nothing
my friends got a show on cbs they're
looking for a garbage man i told them
about you
it's co-star but they're gonna pay uh
1600 for the [ __ ] day
1600 i'm getting 15 spots at the store
that's not bad i love when people in
this industry call and they they're
apologizing about amazing rates i
remember i i got a call someone
apologized and they wanted to pay me
1200 a week and i was making 8.75 i was
like oh i think i'll be able to they'll
be able to uh handle 1200 a week is that
okay
i'm like i think i'll be able to manage
was that joey diaz talking to you no it
was uh i was going to work for hell's
kitchen
it was just amazing how
that salary killed me
i was getting 10 of those i was getting
12 of those one a month
all i had to do was go to warner
brothers or go to sony and half of them
i was auditioning for you know where i
was booking [ __ ] actors access what's
that back page actors access is a
[ __ ] computer page that you go to
you set up a page you put a headshot but
the industry has to go through that
so if somebody wants to see
greg fitzsimmons today you have to have
a reel on actors access and then they'll
email that real with the [ __ ] thing
okay so i set up an account early on
somebody go go to actors access first
thing i booked was a film that flew me
to jamaica i got fired but they had to
pay me a year later
yeah i got five took a year to get the
jamaicans to pay you no sag is a
[ __ ] see if you owe me 1500 sag
wants 4 800.
late fees
movie penalties
so on paper all i wanted was 2 200 bucks
that's all i wanted i wanted what i was
supposed to get the misunderstanding was
not on me
it was clear from sag it was them as
soon as you get on a [ __ ] set as soon
as you touch base in the foreign [ __ ]
land
they're supposed to give you pedium the
script your own hotel room
they wanted me to share a hotel room
with the camera man mm-hmm they never
had a script
wow and they said you have to wait like
a week for per diem what are you [ __ ]
talking about this is a [ __ ] wait
there's a [ __ ] waiter at the
restaurant that's got a tree of weed for
me
for a hunch i swear to god yeah guys
showed up to my room and he had the stem
of a [ __ ] tree
holy [ __ ] lee it was like this
with buds going all the way [ __ ] down
it
just on a [ __ ] stem
[ __ ] that was from the waiter from the
waiter as soon as i got there i went to
the restaurant started talking to him he
came back out and it was in his pocket
he stuck it in there like a knife
are you [ __ ] kidding me
and these people didn't have it i
complained they got pissed off they said
you could take the next plane out
tomorrow i said fine
and i left and then i came back filed
the [ __ ] motion
and then a year later the guy called me
the story was
the guy owned a strip club
and he had a stripper he was in love
with but for her to move in he had to
pay for her first movie
so he went in his pocket and put 300 000
down
put another 150 000 bond through sag
damn oh yeah he was in love with this
just to get her moving
just to get her to love him
like during the shoot there was drama
with him and her he wanted her to stay
in her room
yeah oh she was holding on to a deal
so he got two movie stars to do the role
you ready george jefferson
and the black girl from baywatch
yeah those were her his leading
stars and we're gonna take this to the
cinema and then we're gonna win can
award i'm sitting there going oh this is
a bunch of [ __ ] george jefferson
yeah and he hired him and some waiter
from the strip club to write the script
i saw the first 10 pages like what i was
supposed to read yeah [ __ ] was
misspelled it was it was just a horror
show and it was my fault for being a
[ __ ] gabon
you know
but then what does the job you know you
got to go do a job but then i booked
cold case when coke case first came on
first [ __ ] came out i'm on the
co-case first i showed julie how big i
was when it first came on i clicked on
to one you paid two dollars per
submission
it came up it's the breakdowns
without the big stuff
yeah they hold out the big stuff and
they give you a lot more non-union stuff
if you start now but the early shows the
first season
they don't know what they're looking for
so they go on actors access
bam i nailed the cold case dog and cold
case was great the first season i came
on in february after picked up momentum
nice i'm saying what the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with joey bananas
so then that gets added to your resume
on the uh on the website
so they can constantly see uh what's it
called within youtube
no the one that you uh the the casting
agents look at
face that'll have your resume on it
contact info all that [ __ ]
all that shit's on there when you sign
with a good theatrical agent they take
like they [ __ ] beat you up about that
because they know that's where the
business is now it's not about auditions
anymore it's about me sending your reel
they just call up now and says can you
see what greg fitzsimmons availability
is
from november 25th to december 8th
yep he's available okay can you send
over his real and resume and a headshot
yep okay thank you and then your agent
will call you and say hey you just got
pinned
for those dates then they'll call you
like you forgot about it mm-hmm you've
completely forgotten about it and
they'll call you and they go hey i just
want to inform you we had a quiet
casting call you're not you're not on
hold anymore
i figured that by now you know what i'm
saying it's been a month and a half i'm
not on hold no more well [ __ ] hoopty
let me just kick you while you're down
yeah you don't even realize you're down
it's uh it's it's really changed the the
the thank god for podcast and thank god
for
that's giving people forums and stuff
like that you know
well they got to start making small
movies again you know there's got to be
like
movies that are made
it's so much cheaper now with digital
they can actually afford to pay people
and do these little movies
um
but it doesn't the internet stuff
doesn't add up you'll never make your
benefits if it's just web series
you got to get on network tv even cable
a lot of that stuff doesn't pay
i didn't know i
who the [ __ ] knows anymore who the [ __ ]
knows i know that like
the games are on strike aren't they um
the voice over games all those games oh
i didn't know that yeah those people the
video game vo guys the bo guys
somebody's on [ __ ] strike yeah the
animated people were on strike for a
minute
it's been the problem is that you've got
the actors union the writers guild and
the directors guild all lined up
with the studios and they renew at
different different years
so they'll do a three-year contract or a
five-year contract with the writers
guild the following year they re-up with
sag the following year they re-open that
way the three unions can't come together
and and you know have a front
they split us up
so we have no power individually we got
to all get together in one union
you should put that all together did you
get lisa
what do you think leigh
i don't know i i i like it but it's
weird
it's weird to think like think about
because honestly i'm pretty high and i
didn't hear what you to uh the union he
said
but i was thinking about how like i used
to be an editor and like to hear like
about like all the money like actors and
stuff make
doing like short commercials
it's like it i can understand why people
are going on strike
like all those people when when there's
people making a lot of money like people
at the top of these things are making
listen bro ten years ago
for three or four years in a row irish
sofia
not did great doing commercials he
[ __ ] destroyed him kitty oh he had
like three campaigns early on
that would kill him see even the
campaigns changed yeah
when you would walk into a room it would
say march 3rd through march 18th that
meant you worked five days what did that
mean that yeah so what they were going
to shoot lee's commercial for a day you
sat there and took a paycheck
now it says that but when you get the
call it's for one afternoon
like they don't even give you the the
whole day and it's some overtime let me
go over time yeah listen take your time
go take pictures
don't do something make believe you're a
director talk about your [ __ ] paris
festival whatever you almost got shot
whatever the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] happened to you
you got drunk with john travolta we get
it tell the story again oh my god
it's uh it's such a different [ __ ]
world i was talking to a friend of mine
greg powers today and we were talking
about staying grounded you know how
things have changed in your world
uh
like the [ __ ] i would do 20 years ago i
was never one of those guys that went to
premieres and snuck into parties
i was always none of that i was always a
no-no where i came from the only stuff
that i ever [ __ ] with was the stuff
that i pertain to by the way there's a
movie coming out this week with warren
beatty
you guys see the commercial for it he
plays a he plays that [ __ ] dude oh
right
i'm in that movie no [ __ ] i did a day
what's it called who the [ __ ] knows
they just sent me an email
maybe a month ago
invite me to the screening
i shot this two [ __ ] years ago one
day wow
you're not gonna even see me i know
you're not gonna see me i guarantee they
cut me because i'm not even on the imdb
unless they listed me as mob guys rules
don't imply
rules don't apply
i guarantee they cut my [ __ ] so
you're not going to the party
it was five eight weeks ago four weeks
ago
i they emailed me on a monday for
thursday and i was leaving thursday yeah
i was leaving town so you would have
gone
why not as long as you don't do it all
the time i mean going to stuff like that
once in a while is kind of fun well if
you ever walk into a place
and you're walking around like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and everybody's talking see i
thought you got to bring somebody who
are you going to bring bring a friend oh
what
you got lee
can you me and i'm walking into a place
you down you got nine one one on hold
you got nine one one a whole meal you
walk in the place
me and lee are perfect to rob that joint
lee whips out a machine gun from that
[ __ ]
jacket of his
and i start yelling freeze are you
[ __ ] kidding me we walk in a cuban of
the jew
you could feel the pressure you know
what i'm saying
we wrap around you like my fingers
around that turtleneck
i ain't letting go
i'm not coming on my leg ain't no fool
i got to see a movie i want i want a fan
to make a movie poster of that that
image
no no no no that image should not be
even seen
that's [ __ ] crazy what do you got
going on what else has happened in your
life all the children how's the wife
wife's good
the road where are you at new year's eve
anyway
cobbs in san francisco are you really
yeah
you have
balls of steel who's with you i don't
know
um a couple other people oh yeah it's
one of those shows yeah
15 minutes
15 20 minutes twice two shows done
that's a great [ __ ] show that's a
good gig huh that's a great gig man and
bring the family up i think we'll drive
up the coast for we got the whole
holiday off
drive up to san francisco run around
golden gate park [ __ ] eat some dim
sum
wake up late
be great
not a bad idea for the new years to
really
you can't flirt with the waitresses
though you know if you get your wife
there that's a you got to remember well
why is your wife gonna come she's happy
at the hotel they got pay-per-view
they got room service everybody's happy
the kids are entertaining yeah we play
some board games listen
my wife is great i don't want my wife in
a comedy show yeah for me to do my thing
i can't have my wife in the corner you
know why do you think i don't perform at
home at home
i could perform a mile from where i'm
from bananas
in uh jersey yeah
that's
my whole [ __ ] tribe would come down
there i don't want them hearing what
comes out of my mouth now oh yeah
seriously so you have like a radius that
you won't perform
if they really want to see me they gotta
drive yeah i go to uh i go to a
stress factory yeah which will be an
hour away
and to really throw them off i go into
the city even though i'm from north
bergen which is right [ __ ] nine
minutes from new york city yeah with
hudson county
i know for them going into the city is a
big [ __ ] deal yeah well that's like
talking about southie before there's
people that live in southie that don't
go to downtown boston they don't go to
any other part of boston they just live
the how big is southie
it's like uh
a couple square miles and how far from
that is where we stayed this weekend lee
you were right there yeah we stayed
right next to the wilbur pretty much oh
oh not far not far how far
10-minute drive i walk through there
i get mugged
no i walk through there cause i
combinate ball oh yeah really yeah
there's all irish bars on the corners
you go into those places they'll they'll
spot you
somebody knows somebody
tremendous yeah tremendous
yeah you can have a good time there and
uh but the bars close early what time
two two o'clock yeah and then and then
everyone spills into the streets and
it's all these drunken boston guys and
they all just start fighting i was never
gonna leave and it's not even two most
of it's 12 45.
that's the last call 12 45 when i was
there so yeah yeah so
and i it's it's
so yeah that's it's crazy and something
you can pay but i think it's like
millions of dollars to extend it to 145.
let's get something straight i was never
captain [ __ ] midnight
there was a time where i was forced to
be captain midnight because i really had
no home
so what was i going to go home for
to sleep and think about missing my
parents and [ __ ] like that i got to stay
out yeah i got to stay out it was so
funny when i went home with my family i
took them to rudy's where i've been
eating since i was 17. where's rudy's
rudy's in cliffside park new jersey okay
we used to walk three miles on monday
night football in the dead of the winter
me and this dude named tommy russo and
we'd go in there we were 16 and a half
and they'd service heineken on top
with uh calamari with medium sauce what
are you [ __ ] nuts
we'd be in there living like [ __ ]
johnny la bomba that [ __ ] we'd
make believe we had pinky rings even
though we didn't and [ __ ]
i swear to god in those days it was like
30 bucks 20 bucks and we had it yeah and
i've been going every time i go home i
hit rudy's it's still there still there
i won't even eat calamari nowhere else
like i got pictures of it on my phone
wow yeah yeah perfect perfect and i mean
p if you go there there's two
competitors it's that one it used to be
a place called patsy's patsy's finally
went under but all those years i stayed
loyal to [ __ ] rudy's one time i
disrespected rudy's i went to patsy's
because mikey betoli was taking me out
to lunch and he kept telling me i had to
go i had to go i gotta go but the whole
time i couldn't even that's how much i
respect it's like it's like my passion
for chinese restaurants i have such a
respect for chan's that i had a boycott
california chinese food really like i
finally i couldn't do it anymore because
every time i go home i'd realize how bad
the food i was eating here [ __ ] oh here
my main man
came up to me this week like a man and
he said he went to eat and he realized
the same thing
you forget
and you order it and you order and one
day you go what the [ __ ] am i eating
this ain't beef and oyster sauce this is
beef and soy sauce with onions and yeah
[ __ ] rice i'm getting filled up on
[ __ ] rice and a wonton that tastes
like dick
you bite into a dim sum or a dumpling
and it's a ball what do you think is in
that ball you think that's real meat
that's what they don't use on the
[ __ ] side that's right
but they mix it all together they put
the eyeball yeah with the [ __ ] legs
they throw a little bit of pork balls in
there it's a pig's ears and a pig's tail
and it tastes good that's what gives it
the flavor yeah is the pig but
everything else you're eating they
[ __ ] grind down the shrimp
the tails that's what you're eating in
there they give it that fishy flavor and
[ __ ] people like oh my god
that's a [ __ ] shrimp snail
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah that's some mystery meat
the dumpling meat
there was some chinese restaurant i went
to in boulder i loved them
i adored them they they really saved my
life i could talk all this [ __ ] about
first of all i loved them i loved them
so much i went to work for them
like i called them one day and i had my
daughter with me at the time
that was a [ __ ] bump man
you know
and they came and i was gonna pull a
quick one on them i was going to uh
make them come and say i couldn't find
my wallet
and i went out there like oh you know i
called you and i realized i can't find
my wallet it goes take the food
call me when you find your wallet
my heart broke
that night i went i broke the money and
after that we just became friends the
guy goes listen you ever have a problem
you could put it on the tab your family
i was like really huh i started putting
on the tab
i get a hundred dollars i pay him uh-huh
one day i went in there we need a
delivery driver
uncle joey's here never fear
i was selling coke too at the same time
so i was delivering coke and chinese
food
if you wanted coke you had to buy a pint
of rice something they grow something
shrimp foo young
that's hilarious boulder was great
boulder was really great
like an eight ball i've had a great
[ __ ] time i really had like yeah i'm
trying to write this book and as i'm
writing it
craig it's so weird that
reading the [ __ ] the next morning makes
me sad
but at the same time it takes me to a
certain time period that made me laugh
even though i had that sadness which is
kind of
hard to explain what i'm saying like
jesus
how long have you been writing for
18 [ __ ] years
i'm on chapter one and a half
18 years i'm on one and a half
come on man that shit's got to get out
there i read on writing 18 times nothing
none
you do your 20 minutes every morning
every [ __ ] morning i do a little more
and sometimes i read it the next morning
and i realize i gotta tone the reefer
down or
do more cbd or i'll do something to get
focused
i'm just talking about my life and also
i'm talking about the circus and barnum
and bailey circus and [ __ ] the lap
leopards i'm like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with joey diaz i gotta start from
scratch and move [ __ ] around
you need an editor i need a lot of
things doug and that is the worst thing
uh well that is the worst uh
the least of my [ __ ] nightmares you
know yeah let me ask you something how
were you when you got it together greg
lee and i had a great conversation this
weekend
and he's been haunting him
and it's been haunting me because i
started to make me think
of what aids finally
something hits you
and says how long am i gonna [ __ ] be
mugging people
i think uh well i was never obviously
like you i had a i had gym drinking
problem and i stopped that but
it wasn't until my father died that just
[ __ ] snapped me into it then all of a
sudden i just i just took stuff
a little bit more seriously but i also
had more fun at the same time how old
were you
23. that's when it all came together 24.
you knew what you wanted to do after
that
i want to be a comedian i want to be a
writer and a comedian and uh so in a way
it took a tragedy to
i think so
you know because i think i had a lot of
i wanted to impress my father and get
his acceptance and once that was gone
it sort of let me go after it on my own
terms more like i always felt like i was
still looking for his approval [ __ ]
23 years old doing stand-up i'm a
feature act you know not making a lot of
money but
paying the rent he knew i was a working
comic
but uh but when you come out to see me i
would still like i'd get tight and i'd
walk off feeling like a [ __ ] child
you know
yeah i wouldn't want family to see me
doing stand-up
it would [ __ ] shock me but now i was
just talking to lee
i was about 32
but it was a time when i had to be
brutally honest with myself yeah like i
was really uh
i was just spinning my wheels
i was doing stand-up which was giving me
a little hope and not enough hope
but in the back of my mind there was
hope
but i was just spinning my [ __ ]
wheels and i had to do like an inventory
and i always believe in the abe lincoln
clothes
where you you put your benefits and your
you know like in your uh your benefits
and uh what's the opposite of benefits
definitely cons
excuse me pros and cons the pros and
cons yeah whatever
and boy there was no pros it was like
two pros
compared to 80 cons yeah you know
and you got to be and you were 33
i was about 32 man my world came on my
shoulders i had already been married had
a kid
done time
and i had i was a listen man you know
i wake up and thank the lord every day
because from 20 to 30 i have no idea
i have no idea how
that even happened you know one day you
just 30 [ __ ] two
and you got 32 [ __ ] problems and then
[ __ ] ain't won
yeah 32 sounds about right
you've gone far enough down that when
you make a change it's going to stick
well at 32 i've done it all yeah that's
it i had a i could at 32
i could already written a book
plain and simple that was my biggest
mistake not sitting down right there
because at 32
that was a [ __ ] book already that was
a tremendous book already
then 32
[Music]
by the [ __ ] mercy of god i got on
stage
and that changed me that was like
[ __ ] it like that that it was like a
punch to the [ __ ] mouth
but then i even went more rock bottom
maybe four or five years after that
but i was still holding on to comedy and
i was still going out every night and
doing comedy regardless of what was
going on or how i was feeling
but then i had to make a choice
and i had to write some [ __ ] down and
you know what in hindsight i made the
right choice
i made the right decision i went for it
and you and i are having a conversation
20 years later yeah i can't believe
i left boulder 20 [ __ ] 21 years ago
and it went quick man
it went when did you leave boston
90 well i went from boston to new york
in in 93 and then i came out here in
like 99.
jesus guys yeah
me and rogan we figured the other day we
started [ __ ] 28 years ago or
something
same time same place and uh
very different paths you know he got he
got into sitcoms really fast i mean i
remember when when joe was coming up in
boston he was like the guy other comics
were afraid of like all the the seasoned
headliners they didn't want to go on
after him anymore so all of a sudden he
went from opening
to headlining without ever being a
feature he just went straight to it and
uh
you know he he just uh stuck with it
and
you know that was the same the same time
that you started comedy
was probably when i
that was a turning point that my dad
died and i had just started comedy a
couple years before it
and now it's about getting
getting free again
you know with the kids
the kids that would keep you grounded
correct yeah right
it's uh
i like what's going on right now
you know as i was leaving now we were
watching uh
world news tonight as we do as a family
she has this little pad
and it's her pooter
pooter a computer uh-huh you know
uh
and she was sitting like on my lap my
wife was on the couch we were watching
[ __ ] world news tonight
the black lady died and yeah and the
guitarist died leon russell i'm a piano
player and uh
i look at maurice like emerges i gotta
leave you know
i gotta go to work and she gives me a
kiss and
as i'm walking out the door i said to my
wife i love you
when i hear that little voice going i
love you daddy you know what i'm saying
you're like where the [ __ ] do i want to
go yeah what disco do i want to go to
what club would be vip talking to some
[ __ ] what coffee shop
i don't want to leave here to do nothing
i'm saying like you're like what the
[ __ ] am i thinking yeah right that's why
when sometimes people ask me to uh
you know do their shows some guy's got a
[ __ ]
show at a coffee shop and it's got a
wheel that spins and then if your name
comes up that's when you go on and
you're standing around like an [ __ ]
everybody get there at eight o'clock
show gets till 10 they don't tell you
when you're on no no no no and you're
all supposed to hang around back it's
like i i don't have time
those days are done i gotta go in and
out of there you know the comedy store
runs on schedule
boom they stay right
runs on schedule
you know nobody pops in that they do
they're 15 minutes behind right usually
you bump into somebody you enjoy talking
to any way for 15 minutes right right
yeah scene or something what about
flappers
great place i'm going to be there this
thursday my first time going in a
headliner no just one night
headlining this thursday the 17th i'm
gonna tell you how cool barbara is i'm
in that [ __ ] valentine's day
nine o'clock
she's letting me roll the dice and do
what the [ __ ] i wanted valentine's day
yeah you know the uh room
is where
basically i put the early
footwork down for my special yeah 55
people
no pressure
you do 35 people you sold it out on
tuesday night uh-huh you charge 10-5
hours
you get a little workout
people that want to come see you you you
tell people on the podcast
this is not going to be
carnegie hall mm-hmm greg fitzsimmons
this is greg fitzsimmons with a notebook
just talking from the heart
some [ __ ] you might like some [ __ ] you
know the last 10 minutes i go to [ __ ]
form and close out strong but do some
stuff jokes yeah for 15 minutes it's
just gonna be what's on the notebook
yeah it was a [ __ ] great time
which i should have taped we do have
them all of them lee has all the tapings
all those flappers all those ice house
shows oh you save all those ice house
chests yeah on tape not on video too
right right
i said lee who the [ __ ] knows
who the [ __ ] maybe we'll put them all
together and sell them for two dollars
and donate the money to cats or some
[ __ ] like that
i'll have to buy a cat
that's hilarious
that's the first charity you think i was
[ __ ] cats why not like some [ __ ]
shelter that they don't kill cats they
take a lot of money yeah yeah they got
dirty cats and they gotta pay for litter
[ __ ] love you got some volunteers but
how long you're gonna go in and hang out
with cats
a month and one day you go home what the
[ __ ] am i doing my life you smoking joy
there's some of that [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
going around and all of a sudden you're
sitting there putting your shoes on they
smell like cat litter
you got a rash on your face and [ __ ]
lee where's tony bennett you hook him up
or what
you're slipping [ __ ] second
monday november 14th it's half over
[ __ ]
kick it lee
[Music]
uh somebody
look at me that chocolate took you over
the top didn't it
it [ __ ] put me over the top jack
i don't know what it was but yeah oh i
just went into a deep [ __ ]
i swear to god i just went somewhere
deep into the hemisphere i was thinking
about something you went to college yeah
ever you graduate yeah
i almost graduated college dawg and then
i went to prison do you know that that
was in in boulder in the middle of all
that i was
18 credits away and i was up there i was
rocking and rolling
i had good grades
but
one day the guy came to me he goes this
is the next semester
you got to take like an intro to
sociology
and i had like a a side counselor in
those days i had the
girl i was married to her dad thought he
was like a [ __ ] intellectual and he
used to always tell me don't take those
sociology classes you know
and i'm like uh they're making me take
it you gotta take two of these [ __ ]
dummy classes whatever you describe you
call them dummy classes so i ended up
taking intro to social and something
else
the intro is so sure i don't even
remember what the [ __ ] we talked about
in there
but the other one
was very interesting
we went in there the guy goes i want you
to do me a favor this is your assignment
i want you to watch do the right thing
and tell me what you see
i went home [ __ ] furious
i didn't want to watch to the right
[ __ ] thing
that was the last movie i ever wanted to
[ __ ] watch in those days yeah
when that movie came listen
if it wasn't the charles bronson movie
or steven sagan movie or delivery movie
you were in no [ __ ] danger
but
i paid for the [ __ ] class
i might as well do the right thing i
just do it and wants to do the right
thing
i watch this movie
and the first time i basically peed my
pants
i haven't laughed this [ __ ] hard in
five [ __ ] years yeah no
at this time yeah it'd been six years
since i had been in that
uh new jersey vibe where everybody knew
everybody at the deli
and people said weird [ __ ] yeah but at
the end of the day we hung out you know
the blacks hung out with the blacks
there's a scene in there with the guy
from taxi driver no
we're the guy from dear hunter john
hurt
no no john voigt no john
pump up dear hunter there's a guy we
just spoke about him i did a movie with
him very nice guy
he's the white guy in the deer hunter
that doesn't go to vietnam
not fredo but the other dude
john something is his name
[Music]
anyway let's see here it don't [ __ ]
matter what are we talking about here
what are we talking about talking about
uh starting off in college so john
savage john savage yeah john savage is
doing have you seen do the right thing
yeah john savage is the white guy
that steps on the black dude sneakers
he's from boston oh yeah yeah he has the
boston shirt on and you're from boston
no i'm not i own this ah and they all
you know do the right thing blew my mind
yeah because it let me
where i was living i had i was taming it
down a little bit
but it let me realize i was okay right
and it was about the true meaning about
was the neighborhood and the irish were
on one corner and the jews were on the
other corner and the koreans were on the
one corner and we all said [ __ ] the
irish
and the jews said [ __ ] the irish but the
irish said [ __ ] the jews but at the end
of the day
we all made it work
because we know deep down inside
we do business with one another are you
kidding
you know even though that the spec kid
came over here give me a little bill
where'd he go
you know you know me you know my family
you know my father
you know my mother you know my sister
and then you and then one day your
brother comes into work and you flirt
with my sister
and she walks away and you your brother
says to you
great what the [ __ ] you can't be talking
to these big chicks
but you're like are you [ __ ] kidding
me she brought me a cuban sandwich the
other day look at her in that dress
she's beautiful i would dump my little
stacy for her you know saying
even though but at the end of the day we
all got along
and sometimes
and i'm not listen
i'm not here
sticking up for anybody or voting for
anybody or just saying anything
i think that's what happened with trump
in a way
i think that's what happened with trump
and away
i think he's one dog i say some
outlandish [ __ ]
is it from the [ __ ] heart come on
craig you know people you know it's not
from the [ __ ] heart right but it's
how guys like you and i were raised yeah
you heard the word spit growing up in
boston a few times the [ __ ] speakers
at the store whatever the [ __ ] and one
of you said well you [ __ ] kidding me
that guy's got good cake he's got good
cake in there you have the cake and
they're like what are you kidding me
he's a [ __ ] spec
you know it
but it all works
it's not like you're going in there with
bats with al qaeda blowing up my ice
cream machine and [ __ ]
you know you just say the [ __ ] [ __ ]
store why i grew up in jersey there was
a spec store
on the corner of 40th street right there
they used to make the best cuban
sandwiches and no matter how many [ __ ]
you hated you were in there once a day
for one of those cuban sandwiches
with onions with hot sauce on that
[ __ ] what
in the dead of the winter he had air
conditioning
he was like eating there in the corner
with a nice tea with the cup when they
were [ __ ] still in
cartons
that's how long ago yeah
[ __ ] you
it works i think people
you know listen man
yeah
all right let me give you an example
about a year ago
where the [ __ ] am i
i'm at that sushi place i like over on
mentor
i'm sitting there minding my own
business it's about one o'clock i don't
go in there during lunch time i go there
about 1 30 because during lunch time you
get too many [ __ ] hypocrites going in
there so i go in there around 1 30.
there's nobody in the corner there's a
tv right above me i'm sitting there the
place is [ __ ] empty
also i look up and there's a [ __ ]
chickson next to me between you and i
she can't be more perfect just how i
like him spring dress on
banging asian i don't know the
denomination dirty feet oh she had
flip-flops on yeah even better yeah her
toenails are done
i look over i'm sitting there i'm
looking at it and i'm watching the tv
but while i'm sitting there i'm thinking
to myself what if
what if
i just dove between her [ __ ] legs
right now and there's a [ __ ] right but
by that time the sushi guy came and
dropped that philly roll on me with no
asparagus
and i killed that [ __ ] savage and i
paid my bill and i left but the more the
story is does that make me sexist
you know what i'm saying
does that make me [ __ ] sexist
i'm sitting there minding my own
business the restaurant is completely
open she's got to sit next to me really
yeah really
there used to be a show on hbo when you
were very young called the hitchhiker
yeah i remember that midnight one in the
morning yeah by the guy that was lonely
he'd be hitchhiking and somebody would
bring him home suck his dick every week
scrub his nut sack it was oh my god i
had to be about 11. i didn't jerk often
but i'd watch the whole episode with
enthusiasm
like my head was gonna blow up like
something may write it yeah that was the
first like dirty series yes
it was like this it was like the red
something diary red dress diaries or
something and there was that was it on
like a cinemax on hbo hbo i think it was
hbo hbo
dirty dirty i thought i was like
hitchhiker and he'd be driving he'd be
walking down the road
hbo at first i'm talking about when they
had
the football series yeah 40
something mm-hmm and then after that was
the show the this this is when hbo
didn't have a lot of content
and they repeated the same thing only
out of order
but when when that show was on it was
1983
and it was basically fourth and down
something like that it was a football
show
and then after that was the hitchhiker
or bedtime diaries yeah and then after
that was why am i wearing some [ __ ]
bug
some [ __ ] thing in the theater it was
like a spooky show and by that time i'd
be all jerked up i'd be in bed
[ __ ] that
and the usa had a great show
all night with
night flight oh right
night flight yeah you would get home
early like you'd say wait a second i got
200
i'm gonna drop a g-bow that's a gram i'm
gonna get a quarter ounce of weed that's
another 50. that leaves me with 50. i
got two options here i could take the
g-bow
and do it up on friday night and then
i'm dead saturday or i'd get the [ __ ]
quarter of wifa
get a steak
get a salad smoke some reefer and stay
in and watch night flight that's how
good night flight was yeah
started at nine o'clock you already had
the blankie on your feet all your
friends were out jerking off we had a
great time last night not as good as me
[ __ ] i had a bong with snow in it
with salami sandwiches watching night
flight like a [ __ ] doing a bong
every 15 minutes and [ __ ] and night
flight would end at five in the morning
lee that's when i was a professional
that's when i was lead junior and i
would move to do two things
go to the bathroom or get more salami
out of the refrigerator
that was
it what is it like to smoke smoke out of
a bong with a ass no it is snow that's
how i i lived in colorado
and the snow was right outside my door
it snowed 25 days in a row straight when
i lived there one time like they were
saying it's not gonna snow this season
they're gonna close them i used to
listen to paul harvey then i was a
construction guy i was an electrician
and i just listened to paul harvey the
slopes of colorado are bare you know
they might not be open by thanksgiving
dog it started snowing like on the 21st
and it didn't then until december
you thought you lived in hell
you'd leave your house it was snowing
you'd come home it was snowing
you go to bed it was snowing and you
wake up and it was snowing sometimes
heavy sometimes light
tremendous yeah
it's kind of dark when it's like that
too
it's [ __ ]
snowmass was like a central thing
i lived on the one end of it
and then you crossed over and there was
a hotel named the stone bridge they
advertised on facebook
i see them on facebook now i used to
have a [ __ ] room there i was security
there for about a month or two they gave
me a spare bedroom i had a safe in there
with cocaine like a savage right oh i
was confusing him you were living in the
room not not at all i had clothes in
there
and a toothbrush
and i think twice i went in there and i
would stay in that paranoid and jerk off
and
you know pee in a beer bottle and [ __ ]
and
then in the morning [ __ ] go out there
and throw away the beer bottles and make
believe it didn't happen
i don't remember i don't think there was
a bathroom something was weird about it
it was the security
part of the hotel so they gave you a
room
with a shower but no toilet something
crazy a toilet but no shower i don't
remember what it was
[ __ ] craziness yeah
what's up lisa at my little brother
you're sitting there like [ __ ] goobly
con what happened
no i'm just listening it's uh
i missed when we were driving to foxwood
it was pretty cool
yeah we don't get that around here so
it's like all concrete and dust and oh
you got snow up there wait no there's no
this last weekend i did wilbur on friday
and i did foxes on saturday which i
really [ __ ] enjoyed foxwoods
i really [ __ ] did like it some
casinos you go to you're like i'm never
ever
coming here again
this one i'll be there tomorrow if they
wanted me i wish
they did something i would [ __ ] live
there he just did one night there yeah
that's it i really liked it
they used to have a comedy club there so
i guess they have a smaller room
somewhere
that'd be a nice place to just [ __ ]
hang out for a year crack jokes yeah get
a couple rooms go to the sauna including
massage once a week
i'm getting old i ain't got time for
this [ __ ] no planes and [ __ ] you're
right
yeah i'd like to do a residence man i
would i could do that i could live in
vegas for a year
you know just to do the same gig every
night
keep the door if i can promote it a
little bit yourself i live in vegas and
do a podcast with my main man here
my main man all i got to do is say the
word we're going to move into vegas
and in 30 days he come back to me and
say joey i already looked it properly
online i looked at yelp
oh yeah i'd be i'd be broke in six
months i need like a personal don't go
gambling coach to like smack me every
time because
i would love i love gambling didn't you
gamble this last week i won yeah what
time did you leave to go gamble that's
what i wanted i didn't do it i didn't
spend any time in the room
so you went upstairs dumped your stuff
and went right to the casino the shower
didn't work so yeah this was like
[ __ ]
and what did you play blackjack as
always and did you win yeah how much did
you win 50 bucks i didn't get a five or
a 10 nothing
nothing coming up
nothing nothing this is what i'm living
with some respect four years of college
greg for the same is nothing he doesn't
even come with a cup of coffee doug i
150.
50. this is three dollars but [ __ ] at
least you made a gesture i'll forget
about the 70. you know what i'm saying
i apologize i'll bring you guys
a laptop oh did he yeah he couldn't
bring me a workout he brought me a
lobster tail but it was pretty good yeah
yeah you know
he had a cookie upstairs to something
else
and after we left the [ __ ]
uh uh the horse that wasn't even
the seafood place legal thing legal
seafood he was acting funny
and i knew he was up to something he
went right upstairs and hailed that
lobster tail oh yeah and the fanny pack
he had what was his name the funny bunny
whoopie pie
then he went the next day i walked five
miles i did but he ate a pie and then he
walked back like i'm saying he's trying
to tell me exercise
he wore five miles but he had two pies
and meatball sandwich
he's looking to me in the face
tell him he had a slice
i know this [ __ ] like the back
of my hand
he went there he got ice cream five
miles
he's trying to tell me he walked five
months i remember when we first got here
ralphie may first got signed
by uh the laugh factory and the first
thing jamie said to him was like ralphie
you have to work out you gotta lose a
little weight
so they tried to like get him like a
dietitian and they got him like an
exercise guy
ralph refused the exercise guy he's like
listen i'd exercise on my own
and they're like what are you talking
about like ralphie please he goes i get
up at six in the morning when nobody's
around i walk four or five miles you
know okay
so somebody put like watch on it to see
if this is going on and one day i got
the call you got to go over there talk
to him you know and i actually went over
that knocking the door i opened the door
there's nothing but curtains you think
there's a crackhole in there right oh
yeah ralphie's in the bed just
just covering this bed all you see is
his hands sticking off the matches
and i go ralphy what's up he's like ooh
nelly
he's like coco
man
i just got back from eight mile walk man
he hadn't left the [ __ ] house
no [ __ ] yeah he would never you know
yeah these guys come up to me i had
walked five miles this guy has a hard
time
walking to [ __ ] he walks the subway
sandwich yeah i have i have evidence on
periscope
he's never walked
to popeye's chicken because that'll kill
him
no dude if i walk to popeye's chicken
you have spies in the area no i know you
do listen you can't go to popeye's
chicken and take 92 pieces of chicken
but you go to popeye's chicken and maybe
get a [ __ ] wing and a leg get a
little dirty rice through the dual thing
get the [ __ ] sweet tea and they ain't
gonna kill you
they ain't gonna kill you
you just can't go in there and eat the
[ __ ] potatoes and the french fries
and the [ __ ] why do you quit going
there huh he quit going there no no no
we were talking about it that you know
it's not a bad place right but the
walking set him back three days right
he's trying to tell me he got up in
boston walked five minutes i did you
look like i only had one slow you only
ate once i i
did you eat did you eat on camera no a
lot all right then i didn't eat it but
what did you put on camera then do the
walking okay so the walking's on camera
yes sir but the eating isn't i i just
like the pizza
you know
you know how cool i am i went and i
called and i went and i got the slice of
pizza in between
and uh
and and in the uh the ufc fight i was
trying to get the stream when i got back
i was trying to stream the mcgregor
fight but it didn't it didn't work but i
got the slice of pizza before the fight
came back on
what did you just say to me i have no
idea did you let me ask you something
when you walked the five miles yes did
you eat the slice of pizza did you after
you just walked to five miles and didn't
need nothing we went to legals that's
when you met my mom
so after the five mile walk cause we
went to legals yes sir you did not walk
the five miles
and get a slice of pizza no sir
when was a slice of pizza in the
after i came back
and i went upstairs in between yeah and
i called you like one like what are you
doing i think i'm sitting here and i'm
hungry i'm hungry too call me if you go
eat i never heard from you
never forget you took off that you walk
now that's so at one in the morning you
walk five miles no no one in the morning
walked like two minutes to the place in
the corner i called you too no you
didn't know
nobody knocked on my door with a slice
after you won the 50.
so you won the 50. you didn't even knock
on my dough and slice
a pepperoni pie a soda diet dr pepper
nothing
a t-shirt from the gift shop nothing
this is what i'm talking about ladies
and gentlemen four years at emerson
college they don't teach your [ __ ]
schmoozer 101. no you gotta you know
this guy flew you in he's paying for
your upgrade it's not even forget about
it it's my brother i don't give a [ __ ]
about flying he's my brother i love
bringing him with me he's just you know
he's just johnny bananas when i take him
some places he goes on missions
i i'd rather have
he makes me nervous
because this [ __ ] all walked
eight miles and take a uber for a hot
dog yeah because he saw it on dives
drives and automobiles
that makes me [ __ ] nervous yeah i
don't know what neighborhood this is i
don't know these people right
you follow me and so wherever it is in
jersey we're shooting a [ __ ]
documentary we go to bed at two in the
morning
i go to get them at five there's pizza
boxes and chicken
mcnuggets where the [ __ ] did these come
from i i walked across the street at
five in the morning to the gas station
you know you trust those people
he oh you should have seen the room it
was dominoes it was like
you're giving me like my first major
edibles you're giving me the banana
bread and just leaving me there with
like
dinner three hours ago and we brought
home chinese i left them with an egg
roll no that yeah i didn't get dominoes
that night
oh you got dominoes the night before we
got to kennedy airport yeah i went up
together four in the morning
what's the smell i thought it was a
[ __ ] bella luna you know what i'm
saying he's got pizza in those rolls
cheese rolls and [ __ ]
he's got his feet up like [ __ ] veto
this guy's life he's a [ __ ] lurker in
the middle of the night yeah
and i'm trying like i forgot about
24-hour room service i always [ __ ]
forget it it's worth the extra 50
because you're always hungry at two in
the morning when you wake up yeah and
they don't have the best [ __ ] and they
rip you the [ __ ] off
as you're signing the bill you're like
what the [ __ ] am i doing yes like three
three different service charges oh my
god oh my god you know when i go to
vegas they give you an account so i
don't give a [ __ ] yeah listen i'll pay
you 15 to go get me eggs
if i don't have to walk that walk of
debt downstairs through the cigarette
smoke to the cloud of debt to the
weights of one eye the sadness on
everybody's face yeah three guys like
lee wrestling for a hot dog
every time i go to the south point and i
walk past the hot dog cut i think about
lee and they just put a sign three hot
dogs a lot they have like a picture of
lee
we went to the south point he killed
that black dude that black
lee kept going back and forth like a
[ __ ] yo-yo because it's like 10 feet
from the sports book yeah hilarious
i when when those hot dogs when i put
them that dude turned that side around
i've never gotten more than like two hot
dogs
stop it
stop it late you killed that poor man no
he did not yes because that's a woman
no it's a black dude
what happened was you had like three or
four of them and then i left and you
went back there and you got like two
more and took them up to a room with
like a cheesecake or something
because it's like oh no no they have the
bookie thing
then they got the [ __ ] hot dog stand
but 43 yards from the hot dog stand and
that might be exaggerated it might be
32.
there is a place
that if you're a fat [ __ ]
and you like marijuana
your diet will fail
like whatever system you're on yeah it
will fail
the food isn't bad
but the bakery is on the point really if
you really like bakery stuff and you got
an east coast flat here yeah i don't
know the name of it
lee you know the bakery which uh
uh larry always got us the [ __ ] cake
from right yeah how good is that cake
you took that to your room sucker i mean
it's like uh oh yeah he killed that
[ __ ] yeah so you bought it for
me and then you're like yeah and then
you got mad that i was gonna i didn't
[ __ ] buy it for your [ __ ] i
would never buy your friend larry bought
it for us
and i didn't want and there was an extra
one
and we looked at me like [ __ ] i'll
take it to go i'm like wait you're not
going to eat that
sure enough he got up in the middle of
that sleep walking
did you
oh he's a lawyer
i don't trust her and then he'll go
listen i'll take him to austin and he'll
go like on yelp or something
at least in austin we have our boy bobby
sharon but if not he'll go on like yelp
or something
if they have good ribs
and he'll go to some bad [ __ ]
neighborhood you know just get an uber
and go yeah he's that kind of what i
could do because the
the ribs are good i saw it on tv tv
and next thing you know i'm nervous i'm
like an uncle i lose him on the road i
gotta [ __ ] tell people
what happened he got stabbed at the
mexican restaurant why did he go there i
don't [ __ ] know he saw it on [ __ ]
uh food hub but whatever the [ __ ] it is
so now you gotta go wherever he goes you
gotta be alert
no so i try to take him to good places
to keep his curiosity away but he's just
got this [ __ ] monkey on his back he's
like
joey diaz 10 years ago yeah you know you
got to go somewhere where you're not
supposed to be
last time we went to austin he looked me
in the face
with all the barbecue and all the
poppadoms
he looked me he called me and he says he
was going to take a cab
to an all-you-can-eat chinese buffet
in austin
that's the last place you would even
think about chinese food
this is what boots and butts yeah wanted
to go eat i saved it from myself i had
to call bobby sharon and go bob you got
to help me
you got to take this kid out of his room
to [ __ ]
a barbecue he took him to chewie's he
almost had a heart attack yeah
because if not he's danger to himself
chinese food in austin he's horrible
he's got food poisoning he's giving
everybody food poisoning well china's
food was closed and you're talking about
don't go far away
no there was a lot of things you could
pop a dozers right across the street
with a 19 19-page [ __ ] menu cut it
out [ __ ] why take a chance
i don't know
even columbus wouldn't go to that
chinese restaurant you understand
what else you got going on killer talk
to me always a pleasure talking to you
man i know it's good hanging like on
your podcast we laugh our ass off yeah
[ __ ] he leaves the [ __ ] powerhouse of
the show look how he says something
about lee's presence it just like
makes you not worry about anything
he's like he's like a buddha
i'm happy
i'm happy that
well he's got the watch on look at the
watch
that [ __ ] chocolate put you over the
top yeah is it chocolate uh pot or
mushrooms oh it's it's this chocolate we
used to eat
maybe a year and a half ago and we'd get
desperate
it kicked up it was the very beginnings
of us kicking up the edibles
it said 240 on the box
and him and i would split it
it was 120 and we would get sizzled
[ __ ] sizzled on 120.
then one dad bought like two boxes and
we had to eat it
oh we went deep he almost barfed the
poor guy
but he ate the chocolate we got [ __ ]
up but then something happened the guy
who was making the shipment would let
him sit in his car too long
so he would melt in the wrapper and then
you get them and they'd be like cooked
but now frozen again
so they went downhill for a while well
they made a comeback with a whole new
[ __ ] line
plus different flavors like chocolate
espresso or
something caramel or just some regular
milk chocolate yeah so i was in there
tonight getting the other [ __ ] we get
because we're out of stars even though
we ate one
uh
and i saw they were back and the girls
like that 240 milligrams
people really like them i said you have
to tell me about them me and lisa the
[ __ ] devil two or three times on
i got a package of those and that's what
we opened up but we opened up another
pair of tea first yeah little chocolate
french people you know what i'm saying
nice
and then we went over the gummy bears
this little [ __ ] death gummy
cushy something they [ __ ] kill you
uh-huh you know we go low caloric right
we don't like eating cookies or cakes
no i can just see your guys uh your your
bodies
training
training big time [ __ ] training
i'm telling you i'm [ __ ] sizzled yeah
that chocolate's got my eyes all [ __ ]
up wait 240
that 240 is that normal for uh like if
somebody eats gummy bears how many how
many milligrams we always gotta remember
that we eat a lot of stars of death like
what the amount of stars like those are
the 125s those are the small ones to us
wheat does on bad nights
like anarchy edibles we love anakin
anarchy edibles is our main thing yeah
star one edibles that's what they are on
twitter now they're our main
[ __ ] they always come through
for us
the owners are tremendous the product i
still
i think we've been doing the stars now
for 18 months
and they still [ __ ] catch me off
guard yeah but i know how to do them now
i stay off him for a week
i give him 10 days once i do a start i
won't do him like we're finished
i won't see him now for 10 days
i don't want to see him
are we different and now what
so him and i could devour 1400 milligram
of stars that'll put a regular person in
the hospital
that'll put anybody that i know in the
hospital you start hearing voices
you go deep you get in your car fox will
do this you have a hard time putting
your seatbelt on
but we've built a tolerance to 1200 to
1400
milligrams
so i like to switch it up i'm not
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it's just like cocaine if you show up
with a pound of cocaine
no matter how good it is after four
nights i ain't the same [ __ ] i was doing
the first night now i'm doing an ounce
of it that's where you start [ __ ]
eating up the profit yeah it's the
fourth night because now you're banging
on an ounce the first night you did uh
two grams and you saw the devil the
second night the chick came over she
dressed up like a cheerleader
it's just like marijuana if i can't
smoke the same stuff every day i got
three different four different reefers
and i switch them up
so
with the edibles we do the same thing
so remember we might be able to eat 1200
of the stars
but if me and him would have ate 240 of
that chocolate tonight we wouldn't be
having this conversation right now i'd
be drooling yeah because i could feel
this the gummy bear took us to the
bridge
the chocolate pushed us into the bridge
you know what i'm saying
that's the best way to describe it not
over the bridge nah that's something
george washington would say
he'd be happy right now pop being legal
all those founding fathers they'd be
[ __ ] smiling
saying finally
i just they believed in weed
you know listen you know i love you did
that i don't know the history of wait i
know the history of wheat as far as
1973.
after that i don't know if you guessed
it
you and i don't give a [ __ ]
know about weeds since like 1968
because my mom smoked mary
once a week but i smelt it it wasn't but
they smoked in the cigarettes when they
played cards and [ __ ]
something wasn't up
something wasn't right
but i had a godfather catholicism
godfather
and as crazy as he was he picked me up
every saturday and take me for a
sandwich and watch
a movie on 42nd street and by the end
he'd [ __ ] spark one and he'd start
giggling like oh [ __ ] that's the same
smell i smell at the house once you
start figuring out you're not a [ __ ]
[ __ ] right
and then he would giggle
and crack jokes and show me his gun he
wouldn't act like he did
an hour ago something wasn't right with
that [ __ ] wacky tobacco he got baked
and started showing the gun around to a
kid
that's [ __ ] great he took his gun
after dirty harry
after dirty harry
when he took me to the movie
the whole walk he told me about the gun
it's a 38 magnum whatever the [ __ ] is 44
magnum it's the strongest gun it'll blow
your head off we went to some little
restaurant where there was like a table
across from us
and at the restaurant he goes put out
your hand in the bottom
i saw him fidgeting
it was wintertime so he had a jacket on
and he was fidgeting you know he was put
your hand up he just gave it to me
and he has no bullets and i [ __ ] my
pants it was bigger than [ __ ] and black
because it was the same gun [ __ ] uh
dirty harry dirty harry right
and i almost [ __ ] my pants i gave it
back to him he's like don't tell your
mother
for me to get more action from if i
write them out i'll never get action
from that's a great uncle
godfather
father
that's when godfather's a godfather
that's what people believed and uh
you know when you were somebody's
godparent
it meant that uh
you went to visit them once a month and
you called them
you always sent them like a stupid
savings bond even if there's ten bucks
i had a [ __ ] up godfather
but he was good when i need him saying
he he used to take me to his
girlfriend's houses and
tell me little things about women on the
way home and i'd [ __ ] tell no i don't
like little girls you know what i'm
saying hey tell me something i don't
like girls you gotta suck that titties
you didn't even like girls yet
how'd you say it was titties
oh my god
yeah and then
that's where you learn you gotta have a
relative that tells you little details
about girls
you know
they put like a porno on in front of you
yeah it almost blows up and [ __ ]
my my uh my buddy uh
cuban guy
i won't say his name but uh
his older brother put on a porno one
time when i was probably about 12
and i'm watching it and and i get a you
know i got an erection
and then his his brother's name was
hector and he reaches over and he grabs
my dick
and he goes hey you like this you like
this movie
and i was like what the [ __ ]
i'm like i've never had anybody touch my
dick in my life he just ran out of that
i just [ __ ] you never told nobody
i don't i think this might be the first
time i ever brought it up
it was like one of those memories that's
like lodged back there you gotta run
under a rock
you know my first ever disgusting
experience
was with the ali brothers
i got thrown out of
a sacred heart school for boys in the
fifth grade
and i went to mckinley in the sixth
grade
in the sixth grade there were the
spanish kids called the alis
juan and alberto juan was legit but
alberta was very tired
the alleys
oh just [ __ ] hilarious you couldn't
write this but
in the sixth grade you're 12
maybe 13.
they were like 14 and a half and 16.
like the one that was slow yeah it was
like 15 in those days they just kept
leaving you back that's right you
learned the youngest so humiliating
every night they didn't give a [ __ ] they
were just happy to be in the united
states right they went somewhere from
nine to three they they sang songs they
salute the flag the cubans were happy in
those days are you kidding me they were
[ __ ] the cubans i knew in those days
were [ __ ] the kids were [ __ ] up
oh they were saluting the flag and [ __ ]
going to bible study and singing
they were legit to quit
but the ali's were the first people i
ever met ever
beside
my godfather that ever spoke to me about
sex
and then i had this puerto rican dude on
my block puerto rican nelson he lived in
the back he was a bartender in the city
he used to always ask me and he wasn't a
freak or nothing i always thought that
at one point he would molest me yeah and
even until today i think deep sometimes
[ __ ] puerto rican nelson molest me
because he used to always have a robot
and slippers and [ __ ]
that's how he walked around oh my god
puerto rican nelson
was something you're not sure if he did
you feel like it's maybe yeah like i
think that he ever doped me like you
would pull a cosby on me because
everything about him just like an m.o he
was just a good dude yeah that we used
to go outside and help us fix our bike
and he was a spanish dude he was just
you know he had the sideburns and the
leather jacket and it was the [ __ ]
early 70s and i moved to jersey
and he would talk to a bunch of us and
one day he would take us in the back his
claim to fame with me was that i became
friends with him and i go over there and
he had a black friend
uh that went over to
the rock of gibraltar and he brought
pictures back
and then he would just talk to me and
then one day he asked me
you got a couple of people go to
somebody's house and you go to the house
a lot and they're sober but one day you
catch them in their [ __ ] hammond
yeah and we go over there and it's like
early in the morning like i used to go
over there every morning at 10
and wake them up and and
what's up man what are we gonna do today
give me an hour i'll go out there and
play stickball with you and he came out
with coffee and he wreaked of alcohol
yeah
you know he was one of those dudes in
the summer
you know no air conditioning just a
dynamite dude yeah and one day i knocked
on the door and he answers with a towel
around him and he's sitting down like
he's all [ __ ] up
like well nelson you're going to play
football he's like man not today you
know and all this [ __ ] he goes come back
in like two hours so you know in those
days you're punctual yeah like we were
there in two hours
he answered though you guys again the
[ __ ] curtains were still up he
invites us in he's got a towel on
you know he turns the light on and
there's like a table filled with alcohol
you know and like oh yeah how old are
you at this point 12
12 and i can't remember
who the [ __ ] i walked in there with like
it was like six of us in the
neighborhood that liked nelson
but two of us actually interacted a
little closer with nelson yeah i was
spanish so i understood nelson's world i
knew puerto rican people but i can't
believe who
was the other guy
that mingled with nelson so we had woken
nelson up he goes come on come here we
sign his couch you guys want a soda he
gives us a certain he puts the tv on you
can see he's still [ __ ] up the night
before he's got the towel on
and he's like so you guys get laid
and we don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about like nobody ever spoke to
me like that
i had uncles that would ask me how
anybody suck your dick yet yeah are you
pissing sweet yet that type of [ __ ] but
this
oh yeah yeah when you're spanish
yeah it's a great line
but nelson was basically the first
person ever but like i known about sex
but nelson was the first person ever
that said it could be yours you know
it's like
like what do you mean you never had sex
i got a girl right now she'll come over
and clean your pipe you're going like
and we're both like [ __ ] [ __ ] in our
pants
yeah you come up with like ten dollars
we're like nah nah nah
so that was it he never talked about it
again
and then when they were sitting there
like a mother just saw this guy
like a guy in a [ __ ] towel as
neighborhood boys over and offers to get
them all over
and he's drunk because he's outrageous
they haven't had sex at 14 or 12.
so he's cool as
[ __ ] he used to play bad basketball with
us and [ __ ]
so one day i go away with this kid and
he starts telling us what's his name
again puerto rican nelson
is it be capitalized no puerto rican
nelson was cool as [ __ ] because he used
to bring us weed from the city
and he would actually give us seven
joints for five dollars wow he really
took care of us it wasn't like he was a
bad guy which
to me meant the world because a lot of
people could bring your weed over in
those days but they say i take a joint
off the top he was like i gotta go over
anyway
don't worry about it the guy gives me a
better deal
so i always liked them because of that
so one day we're there and a church and
the girls there
a girl comes out of his bedroom me and
my buddy like wow
look at puerto rican now someone abroad
she sits on his lap and [ __ ]
and he's like yeah this is my girl he's
feeling her up and he's making that in
front of her
and feeling into these issues
and me and my buddy are frozen like
we're just i can feel i can i can't
remember
who the [ __ ] it was
so how old was this guy this guy had to
be 28 and the bro was like 21.
but he was he was one of those he had to
be 26 maybe he was from somewhere else
and he lived there this before the
computer before neighborhood watching
before
and no one was freaked out by a pack of
12 year olds hanging out with them no
because in those days a lot of parents
came out
and played with kids i know that's
different now so you
in those days we wanted to go into the
murky waters yeah and he was kind of
opening the door not really to be honest
here it took a long time it's not like
he lurked us into his house and said do
you guys want to have sex this is after
we knew him for a year right we go back
there all the time to get one after a
basketball game we knew him you know
but now he knew we were growing up and
he knew what our needs were i look at it
now like he was he was just trying to
but we couldn't handle it yeah so one
day was sitting back that we had a
basketball game and he's like hey man
what'd you think of that [ __ ] broad
the other day me and my butt like oh she
was banging he goes i'll tell you what
he goes tell these guys how hot she was
and me and my buddy's like yeah
she was hot he's like oh when can we see
it he goes listen
i think what i'm gonna do
he doesn't listen i'm gonna [ __ ] her
tonight in the living room
and i'll leave the window open you guys
can come by and listen
[Music]
that was his thing for like a dollar
we all ran away we were like butterflied
we got there 10 minutes before he
started [ __ ] it
we're like not even in there and also
you heard her oh
oh he's like yeah
we tried to look
there wasn't an eight of us
look at that window
we just heard them [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
heard meat like that's the first time i
heard balls yeah and we ran out of that
dog the next day
the next day he's like you guys come by
oh my goodness
that's the weirdest [ __ ] neighborhood
guy i've ever heard
oh my god holy [ __ ]
that guy's great
but the ali brothers think about how
many like first you had with that guy
first drinking [ __ ]
no no no no he got us weed and he was
like dog if i do this for you you got to
keep it on the level i can't have you
know he was very careful but the ali
brothers were the first per people that
told me like this all was happening at
once so i was living on giving a
terrorist but i would play on 26th
street
and the ali brothers were hysterical the
ali brothers were the first people i
ever met in my life that went to a
hooker house
and they would both describe the
experience to me and it was like a
[ __ ]
perfect film you couldn't write this now
my memory because juan ali was very
intelligent and he would say yeah you
give him 10 bucks
and you go in the back room and they
[ __ ] take your shoes off and they
take a bucket out and they wash your
dick
and they get on the bed and they ask you
what do you want to do
if you want a 69 and we do everything
and we do everything we're there for
like an hour we eat them
they give us a massage the whole [ __ ]
when you're [ __ ] 12
and a 13 year old's telling you this
[ __ ]
you're my it's like pink floyd the first
time yeah you go home and think about
that [ __ ] and think about the
possibilities like maybe i'll go over
and i'll put on my best suit
i'll get 10 bucks and see what the bronx
has to offer are you [ __ ] kidding me
but every monday there'd be a circle
around these two
and they'd be telling us all their
sexual extra pains you know
the [ __ ] ali brothers until i hit the
right thing right next to where they
lived was a company called duratest
and they made light bulbs
all sizes they made these things but the
best thing for us as kids
was when they made the office the skinny
long ones yeah oh
all that i could hit you in the head 25
times nothing will happen they just
break and you get white powder on you
okay
so we would jump over the dumpster
get like 150 of those things and
everybody would take an armful and we'd
go to war with each other no [ __ ]
we'd hit each other no cuts never never
a misunderstanding and it was me juana
lee
martin perez
all these what dean lapreed all these
white dudes from 2016 were all out there
but there was a roof
a flat roof over a garage
next to one alley's house and there was
access to the roof so we're having this
war five on five everybody's hitting
each other with these [ __ ] things
i run to the roof i'm having my own
private war up in the roof
and somebody throws a rock over they
throw a bulb over right
then another bulb comes over ah
and then a rock comes over well i take
the [ __ ] rock and i look at the guy
and i don't say that and i throw the
rock up up in the air right and i just
leave it like that also here
and we look over not the smart ali but
the [ __ ] one alberto the one that
used to always say see you're look at my
song yeah like he was the one that he
was like louie he's like that character
louie that wasn't intelligent
but he was going yeah yeah yeah i was
there he was that guy but i hit him in
the head with that [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i
clocked him right here didn't break but
he got a lump immediately like a
hematoba yeah but it was a hematoma that
got that pus went right to it
and he had a little pee hole in it you
could see and he was on the floor
he's on the floor like my friends didn't
give a [ __ ] he got in the head with the
rock they give him what light bulbs and
[ __ ]
this is
why he was down by the time we got to
him he had powder all over from the
light bulbs but you can still see the
lump on his head i'll never forget it
till this day i always look them up on
facebook and google them i can't get a
hold of them and that's how they spelled
their name ali
a-l-e there's a human name
yeah
oh my god i still think
and juanalee
and what and how funny they were
together it was like the first comedy
team i encountered
where you're from you encountered two
dudes
who one was just [ __ ]
but he had a friend he was the brains of
the operation whatever the one that i
did the other guy did yeah right they
were both union dudes yeah they both
like this uh the pats yeah
you know no you keep thinking i'm a
boston guy i went to college in boston i
started doing stand-up in boston but i
grew up in new york okay that's
town new york what the [ __ ] is wrong
with uncle joey lee now everybody thinks
i'm from boston you can't give me those
edibles dog i i i don't you don't get
invited to a cam neely thing yeah oh you
did what you did yeah i've done that a
couple times you didn't do it this last
time no you heard about wanda right
wonder who wanda sykes did it i guess
last night
or maybe the night before and i guess
she was doing some material about trump
and the crowd started booing
and uh she i guess she just kind of had
it out with them
and then then she gave him the finger
and then apparently apollo went up to
and didn't do very well he was
pretty offensive they said
yeah i mean they didn't like him
you're comedians you're at a [ __ ]
comedy show
you know the crowd just got to accept
that i always thought that comedy was
how your world
collided with the rest of the world
right okay
that's what i was raised to believe
i say some [ __ ] up [ __ ] even in the
special i say some [ __ ] up [ __ ] about
what i feel not about how
you know i'm sick and tired of hearing
about how
uh illegal immigrants are ruining the
[ __ ] country there's some good
immigrants that have come here let's
face it we're all [ __ ] immigrants
okay
i think we got to do a better job you
know controlling do i want to be trump
jr and deport everybody come on
what the [ __ ] that's what's bothering
people the most right now
you know that's what's bothering people
the most right now
um
yeah it's a non-issue they brought it up
during an election year but it's not
affecting people's lives the way the
national news makes you think about it
you know i'm an immigrant man my mom's
an immigrant i'm [ __ ] every day i
wake up i'm happy to be here you know
i'm ashamed i have a felony we're going
to hide it from people
and then someday it comes on abc news
comedian joey diaz has been walking
around like ego's a christian
yeah meanwhile he got arrested for
kitten that when he plea bargained the
[ __ ] second degree burglary you know
that's now people like why didn't you
ever tell us so i was embarrassed are
you embarrassed about it yeah it's a
bill's character yeah it's like a hitch
in the [ __ ] service
right lee what are you sitting there
[ __ ] look at your eyeballs like a lot
of cigarettes your eyeballs right now
they're so red
you look like one of those [ __ ]
jewish people that not you don't you own
like a shoe store and you'll take what
they give you you know what i'm saying
right now you got that look to you right
now like listen to sneakers 14.99
but it's thursday it's 10 o'clock you
caught me on a good time
i'll do this deal right now for 13.50
plus tax
yeah but it was 14.99 no it was 14 15
right i'll do it for 13.59
plus you just told me 13.50 that was two
minutes ago
it's 13.59
right now it's 1409 so
make up your mind
do you not want to sneak in or not
i'm [ __ ] stone jack i'm having a
great time on a monday night i got a lot
of [ __ ] tomorrow joey o'neil you know i
love you it was great meeting you my man
jack
yacht
i love you [ __ ] robert navis jeff
morris liar hernandez lady jay great
senior shet rogers
joseph raphael
and my main man my cousin who hit me up
today and said somebody came into his
[ __ ] jiu jitsu studio i said you
heard about him on the podcast i'll tell
you what man
i grew up with [ __ ] julio we both
grew up with book making [ __ ] parents
that's how i grew up with julio you go
to his [ __ ]
school after class asked him to tell you
stories
about we were like maybe 13 on saturdays
no we were like 11
because i was going to catholic school
so on saturdays
mandatory i would have to go to the
bronx with him
and go get donuts for the guys run
errands pick up money like we pick up
like hundred bucks and think we were
gangsters you should like i picked up
100 today would you pick them and they
would pay us like 100 for the day
for like six months me and julio would
do that and every saturday was a
different location
because they kept moving around so the
apartment wouldn't get raided
[ __ ] tremendous i mean that's how he
grew up then he became a cop
and i became whatever the [ __ ] i became
and we had we we both went to war in 85.
oh yeah yeah he told me the cops are
looking for you and if i see you again
i'm gonna arrest your people looking for
you you pissed a lot of people off and
i'm thinking i'm looking i'm going i
grew up with you yeah are you [ __ ]
kidding me i grew up with you you're
telling me this [ __ ]
he's like i wouldn't be here if you if i
was you
so i didn't talk to him for a long time
and i held like a resentment but then we
started talking about six years ago and
now i'm pretty tight with them i still
love them the way we did when we were
kids you know what we're gonna do
but if you're in lindhurst or any of
those areas carl stat
monarchy like a [ __ ]
connie any of those areas man
go give anaconda jiu-jitsu a try tell
him that you heard it on the podcast and
it'll give you a couple [ __ ] days for
free he'll teach you how to hip escape
and that's that all right yes nice deal
no he's a great guy
he's it's the holidays
he could always need a [ __ ] economic
boost you know what i'm saying he's a
great jiu jitsu teacher he dedicated his
life to that so he's
[ __ ] 20 years he's one of those
[ __ ] morons that he goes to
competitions and the whole deal you know
what i'm saying
what else is going on dog tell me your
story put my volume on a little louder
i'm a little on the low side tonight
well you ain't producing over that
[ __ ] you're over there in wawa
land
looking around thinking about what
you're eating when you get home
you don't think i know you i'm not going
for a three-mile walk
he tried to sell me that one i went to
chandler i did then i went down the
[ __ ] mountain and i walked over to
ventura look at that
you went to chandler you looked around
you said jesus christ i'm going to get
by a cop
you turned around and you went home and
you said woof
it's a tough [ __ ] life we live here
i walked from
magnolia and little canadian
to chandler and little canyon and then
to chandler and colfax and then from
calpex to
magnolia are you sweating
yes
obviously
joey's getting a call
who is it that's what all this is
all right so you went for that you got a
little suntan yeah it was such a [ __ ]
beautiful day
it was one of those days where you wake
up you go to do something you go wait a
second i gotta look at my schedule
i'm gonna have to cut some [ __ ] out
today
some people are going to be disappointed
i had the 4 30 in hollywood over the
hill
that's the first call i made so yeah i
woke up i sent the email so it happened
today the babysitter didn't show up
that's not happening i may do the local
[ __ ]
but going over lower canyon
i don't even know is it for an audition
no
what the [ __ ] they want to see me about
who the [ __ ] knows that yeah
just get in the car and go you know what
i'll see you the week after thanksgiving
yeah the traffic slows down a little bit
you kind of enjoy going down there
you're bored up in the valley i've been
bored i'm locked in i'm time to go to
[ __ ] hollywood and run with the big
dogs in the daytime and [ __ ]
take a meeting with these [ __ ]
but now you wake up on monday i just
flew back sunday from boston six hour
flight yeah it's a long flight even jet
blue it's a long [ __ ] flight
three hours you still got three to
[ __ ] go it's still like 2 45 you're
like
oh my god thank god i caught that's when
the fighter came on fx
but i had commercials see
but it was still entertaining to me i
loved it i loved that movie
he's one of the best actors working
today that [ __ ] dude the other one
the one without no teeth he plays batman
oh yeah he's tremendous he really is
yeah what's up lee
you're looking all tan you're looking
like dj [ __ ] habib
what's his name what's the rapper j
khaled
dj khalif look at this [ __ ] oh you gotta
just start rapping you gotta get like a
jet ski and throw a hundred dollar bills
in the air you're assuming i can't rap i
never said nothing i know you're listen
what these people don't know and [ __ ]
greg fitzsimmons don't know is you're an
international superstar back in israel
i've been telling people for years when
they go who's this [ __ ] guy i'm like
who's this guy who the [ __ ] are you
[ __ ]
this guy was a director in israel won
the [ __ ] patapu
whatever film festival
rap superstar
what was it rap superstar and
international rap
superstar you understand me at least i
had to [ __ ] around
he lost his hair on a chemistry
experiment
they did something like with the michael
jackson thing on stage and that was the
end of him
he takes some risks and
he lose something he wants them he got
like eight mil in the settlement
egyptian money
but he got like [ __ ] three mill
americans he lent me a hundred grand and
here we are you know i'm saying i'm
paying
[Music]
you gonna write it all down lee
i should have been
but
no i have
maybe i will eventually lee had a good
time this weekend that was thank you
people if you came to the show
it was a great experience for me
you know uh i don't know the last year
and a half greg i've been getting
anxiety i get it at two places
i get it at the comedy store when i walk
up those little steps
what on the street
uh oh walking up to the stage
yeah walking up to like the littles you
know when you first get to the store
yeah
and uh
beautiful boom
when you first get
to the comedy store you're in the
hallway you get your water you go to the
bartender you give the waitresses a hug
yeah i see greg fitzsimmons i give him a
hug i see lee i see [ __ ] theo vaughn
i gotta get back on the podcast you know
what i'm saying
you're talking to him bobby lee you give
him a hug and also you look at the list
and also he's got the light and jeff
comes up to you and says you got to get
on stage and fight he just got the light
joe i just saw that you got five minutes
maybe seven maybe eight right there i
stop the conversation
and i walk up those stairs i get to the
top
i look around sometimes i sit down
sometimes i stay in the corner and
brother right there
my world just goes
so i usually take the chair
and i start breathing
deep breaths into my [ __ ] stomach and
i breathe out deep breaths and i pray to
god the comment goes long keep going
[ __ ]
run with it [ __ ] and it stays at like
40 percent
and once he starts closing up i get up
and right there i get a little bit more
to about 55
and then on the way up i actually have
to pace my steps
and not let my breath go up
because if my breath goes up and i'll
let my anxiety goes up i will [ __ ]
pass out right there and by the time i
hit the stage at the store he put some
music on
he put some disco music on i dance and
i'm 30 percent
the opening line i get a laugh so i'm
running at like 10
if i make it to the 11 minute mark and
i'm okay
it all goes away
and now i'm just running on punches to
your [ __ ] head
till you fall down like [ __ ] eddie
alvarez it's over right
it's pretty interesting but so how long
has that been going on
maybe like 18 months yeah doesn't happen
on the road no other no other clubs just
every once in a while it goes up to
about 60. yeah but i catch it
i breathe
and it goes down to 15 i go on stage i
say what's happening [ __ ] yeah
they giggle we run with that right there
we run with the other
10 that's left
just get your adrenaline it's like mad
max when they're right on them he kicks
that adrenaline up yeah that's that last
10 that really goes into your act if you
use it properly you don't
it's like a weird fear that you
and as it's coming out of you you can
feel it coming out of your legs
coming out of your nutsack goes into
your stomach yeah and next thing you
know they're laughing and now
it's not the trans
they're caught in
as much as the trance you're caught in
it's kind of weird when you're rock and
roll at the 18 minute mark
you know it's a certain cardio mm-hmm
it's like uh
they say cardio isn't really effective
on those machines
unless you do 20 minutes then after 20
minutes is when you really burn fat
i believe the same thing on stage
sometimes yeah if you think about it it
takes you a little while to get going
you take a breather for ten
you pace yourself and then you [ __ ]
just go out there like a [ __ ] lunatic
yeah
i don't [ __ ] know what i'm talking
about so wait what's the other the other
place you feel anxiety oh yeah not the
wilberth eater
it was brutal really oh
it hadn't been that close in a long time
i get that type of anxiety
when you tell me you gotta take blood
from me
like that's the anxiety that when you
walk in the room
and you're gonna be all right joey this
is what we gotta do we gotta take a
little blood sample
no matter how you say it to me i hear
organ music right afterwards yeah
dumb
like [ __ ] my body goes numbness
oh it's been like that oh
since i was a kid ugh that sucks i go
deep into a [ __ ] thing i've
controlled it
the last couple years for my surgery a
few months ago from my nose
it was horrible because they kept
missing the vein
see if i don't feel any pain and i
breathe right put the ipod on
uncle joey's cool as [ __ ] if you start
missing veins and [ __ ] you have time you
gotta do it again that's where
that's where it goes [ __ ] bananas
so even at the blood sample a week later
you have to go to the hospital seven
days before the surgery
i had that first beast and after surgery
they couldn't fit the [ __ ] thing in a
vein in my arm
my feet are going numb just talking
about it
and then they profoundly i said put my
[ __ ] vein in my hand yeah and it
worked in there and then i woke up and i
had
uh
straws in my nose held with bob wire
from guantanamo bay
jesus christ you know what that's like
for a guy like me oh
[ __ ]
and then like you gotta spray uh saline
solution in there and shit's gonna come
out on their own oh my goodness
oh molly good golly i'm getting dizzy
just thinking about it what's that where
you blast the saline in one nostril
comes out the other oh you just blasted
the nostrils also these chunks start
flying out yeah
yeah and at first it's disgusting but
then it goes 50 50 it becomes
you get into it
it becomes
half's not that blood it's like it's
like a clam on a half shell without the
salty it's got already come
you just eat those [ __ ]
please don't eat any more burgers in
front of me
i got one of these things in my nose
it's like a one of those things that
grow on your skin
a lesion like a beauty mind
a beauty mark what do you call those
things
like a mole a mole i had one in my nose
from 30 years of doing blow i was pissed
i don't want to take it out with the
surgery but in that mold like if you
squeeze it once every 10 days a
tremendous old-school snack comes out
like like
one of those
no [ __ ] way like one of those cokes
nuts like i'll feel it too i'm like
that's feeling heavy there
and also i'll be sitting and i'll
squeeze it squeeze it and i'll feel like
something thick
i'll just pull it out and it's like a
inch and a half
with different flavors and different
apparent tips
some parts of it is heavy it's thick
it's gooey it's like a [ __ ]
halloween treat
and it's there every 10 or 12 days oh my
god
i can count for an hour enjoyment with
every 10 to 12 minutes
i don't know i don't know what it's took
an hour
because that's how long i chew it for
until it dwindles into like a little
white head then i spit it into the air
let it land wherever it goes
why am i so [ __ ] hot
he's at flappers this thursday which
makes it the 17th
of november right say joey how do you
[ __ ] know that i'm going to tell you
how i know that because i'm in houston
on the 18th
nice i've been thinking about [ __ ] uh
i always [ __ ] think about this [ __ ]
in november
and i always go wow that happened this
long ago yeah like who was i then who
was i now am i the same person
would i put a gun to your head over a
[ __ ] bag of blood i wouldn't even
give a [ __ ] yeah i'm saying
it's amazing how you change so this time
of the year
it gets a little [ __ ] up for me
i'll call the victim on thursday say
hello the victim yeah i still talked to
kent he called into the podcast once
yeah
i just talked to him about two months
ago i don't think kent ever stopped you
know what i'm saying like kent uh
i met kenton boulder kent was a good
looking dude in boulder who picked up
tail
he knew the right people he hung out
with the right people those right people
supplied him in a [ __ ] car
that's how right those people were not
just any car
something right off the line that it was
a it's a it was a bmw store
so he come to town he'd go let me get an
audi take it kent
kent you're gonna come here on saturday
and sell cars and kent was a good
looking dude and he going didn't sell
three bmws on a saturday yeah
you know so
but now we talk he lives in new mexico
he loses his mother he says he lives
with his mother because she's sick
whenever he leaves me a message it's
always late at night yeah and he always
sounds a little whacked right i was
there so i know what wack sounds like
when i get him in the daytime he sounds
completely different a little bit more
corporate
but i can feel something he doesn't talk
to sam because when i saw him after i
kidnapped him
i kidnapped him in 87
but i saw him again in 93. yeah i
actually bought blow from him at a bar
six years after you kidnapped me yeah i
never saw him again and one day walking
to pearls
and then he is dancing like oh can't
what's happening he's like what the [ __ ]
he goes hey man i go hey kent i'm sorry
you know i said how are you doing
everything all right yeah he was [ __ ]
up like okay
who's got the grandma blowing this
[ __ ] he goes i do give me the
money i gave him money gaming
because i can't believe you're kidding
at me you [ __ ]
and that was it
that was it i knew [ __ ] never saw him
again
and then facebook came along and one
night you're high you're doing blowing
you're like let me see how if ken bell
is on facebook and there he is
and i start hitting him up and [ __ ] you
he would send me those things on on
just [ __ ] around no you were serious
at first really
it took about seven years man for him to
finally cave
however long fight because i i started
nagging him on myspace
i started nagging him on myspace
and that's where he would send me
something back that was nasty and
tommy the [ __ ] off
it was crazy and then when myspace came
facebook came along
i got high one night on reefer and there
he was in the very beginning of facebook
and i tried to friend them nothing
there was a couple people i tried to be
[ __ ] friends and they were like [ __ ]
you why'd you want to be friends with
this guy so much
because you felt guilty
sure
you know let my listen i didn't hit him
i never hit him in the head with the gun
and so i could kick them i didn't abuse
them i'm not that type of person
it was all about people say it was
business bro
you came into my life at the wrong time
and you didn't [ __ ] cover your ass my
friend
you you're dealing with the [ __ ] big
leagues here
you're not dealing this ain't [ __ ] a
tv show this ain't breaking bad
you know you're gonna meet some dude on
the street and tell them you want to
[ __ ] you have two kilos of blow
what do you think
happens what the [ __ ] do you think
happens
the word gets up
that means every barracuda is gonna
[ __ ] look at you and go
this guy's easy pray
all you gotta do is get ten thousand
lure him into an alley
tom the money isn't the thing you wanted
to see the blow and when you take them
they just punch them in the [ __ ] head
and you take the ten thousand well who's
he going to say what's he gonna say
he stole the blow himself
you're following me he stole the blow
himself what was he gonna say
i was young i was very stupid i'm not
proud of it but
it's who i am today what are you gonna
do
you own it yeah what are you gonna do
what do you want me to do hide it and
uh try to hide it from my resume it's
there
i ever get a show on cbs i go into a
meeting with you
and they go we love the show but there's
a problem we did a background check
which they do before they give you a big
check did they just give you a big check
they want to make sure you're not a
[ __ ] offender in the neighborhood you
know what i'm saying oh now that now
let's check your twitter and your
facebook everything yeah oh yeah no it's
it's serious
what do you think they're going to do
they're going to [ __ ] look at your
[ __ ] uh
make sure you're not [ __ ] giving out
lollipops in culver city after three
o'clock you know what i'm saying
going down the corner in culver city at
the [ __ ] thing giving out lollipops
to get with messages
like little fortune cookies today's your
lucky day
little spanish kids if you're signed
here trump ain't gonna deport you but
come to the movies with me
i'm taking you to see moana it's about
filipinos what is it about polynesian
people mexicans with [ __ ]
bikinis on same difference come on
lollipops for everybody you all sit
around with michael jackson's style
have some jesus want where's the jesus
juice
it's really [ __ ] weird how these
people act and they get away with it i
if you're that [ __ ] stupid you don't
see it coming around your kids
you got to keep your eyes open you know
what i'm saying yes it's a tough being a
dad isn't it yeah
you ever look at somebody and go this
guy's a pedophile
no we had a pedophile in my neighborhood
though who we're friends with
he was uh
you know he was a guy who lived a block
from us that we all our families hung
out and known him for 15 years
and then one day uh
we find out he went to jail for
being a pedophile in the neighborhood
falling out of a tree with a with a bag
football
yeah giving out baseball [ __ ] cards
this [ __ ] like those carvel ice cream
cones
he would show up with like the team you
wanted right you're trying to get the
mets but they always give me the cubs i
got it for
you it was [ __ ] creepy man
you know man i gotta look you guys both
in the face and tell you
i got into some bad [ __ ] situations
i really did
and that's one situation
the good lord knows i [ __ ] thank them
for not
you know who bro when you do drugs who
knows what happens to
you go to somebody's house pass out next
thing you know they cause beat you
mm-hmm
you wake up with chains around you you
get [ __ ] in this 10 cameras right
you come back the next day with the cops
it's a [ __ ] priest house with [ __ ]
crosses on the walls i'm telling you
yeah right perverts took me down i've
been here for 28 years
it smells funny but
oh god i gotta stop eating these edibles
really i'm getting too old for this [ __ ]
these are strong my chocolate's strong
as hell what are you going to do tonight
what do you got to eat at the house tell
me the truth
uh i think paula made chicken rice
what type of chicken
i don't know barbecue
she made that last week what type of
rice
i think she make i think she made
chicken rice chicken rice look at you
yeah chicken fried rice you're a regular
[ __ ] lucky dude no lasagna nope not
yet oh yeah
no blue apron
uh blueberry came last
last week i think it's coming on friday
actually
we're talking about those chocolate
covered strawberries that we used to do
ads for
yeah
oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] berries what
happened to those things i just remember
where uh everybody got involved they're
back they're trying to make a comeback
are they yeah yeah yeah somebody sent me
an email with like a list of people if i
was interested
mark them down
cherries berries is trying to make a
[ __ ] comeback really they're off to
two dollars per chocolate piece
they moved on to green and pastures
they're looking to [ __ ] up the annie
and see if you're interested yeah
valentine's day yeah there you go nah i
don't want to [ __ ] send chuckling to
people's houses
that's [ __ ] up why i got a couple
boxes sent to the house stuff one was
good the other one was men's and men's
yeah yeah the other one was like take
your own chances yeah i grew up in a
place
10 minutes for a place in family new
jersey that on fridays
you couldn't even go up that hill
because
the whole side of that street across the
street was double parked
while you were there they dipped the
strawberries right in front of you
krauses
krause's in fairview
on fridays
it was chocolate-covered strawberry
shack they just hand it to you no you
had to pay some gidas they're not giving
you a dick no but i mean they they dip
it and hand it to you right now what do
you need six of them give me six of them
pablo
in the box the box would be little boxes
it's 12 boxes the [ __ ] lee sciat box
the joey diaz box because i go in any 12
of those [ __ ] and they were all
hand-picked this is the [ __ ] 80s
every strawberry was still wholesome
they would and they'd dip them in that
perfect chocolate and then he put like a
vanilla thing on top of it just as a
[ __ ] kick to the stomach yeah oh my
god you took them to the car and you
could still feel the chocolate molding
it's like when you get that dairy queen
ice cream
and they dip it into that chocolate and
they give it to you right away come on
dog yeah it's nothing [ __ ] better the
greatest it's the [ __ ] greatest yeah
same thing with that [ __ ] how do we get
talking about that anyway speaking about
eating you got to sleep too sometimes
you can't sleep you got insomnia you
walk around you eat [ __ ] hugging
doozies
you smoke some tootsie roots
and you can't sleep
what it is is your [ __ ] matches see
you're unique you don't walk like
everybody else you don't talk like
everybody else and you don't sleep like
everybody so why is your mattress one
size fits all for years i had one of
those mattresses you buy for 200 at a
[ __ ] farmer's market 50 dollars
whatever you thought you were the king
of the world then you wonder why you're
at the chiropractor 18 times a [ __ ]
week
it's your mattress [ __ ] well guess
what
and
anyway
you don't talk like people you don't
sleep like everybody so why is your
mattress one size fits all like i said
because this custom mattress will cost
you five to ten thousand bucks until
today introducing helix sleep where you
can buy mattresses online customize for
hundreds of dollars instead of thousands
go to helix
go to helixsleep.com
answer a few simple questions based on
four
key preferences and the result will be a
custom sleep profile used to build you
the most comfortable mattress you'll
ever sleep on your mattress will arrive
at your door in about a week and
shipping is a hundred percent gratis
and for couples gradus means who gots it
means free 100
free okay that's what you want to hear
and for couples helix sleep customizes
each side of the mattress helix
customers report a 30 improvement in
overall sleep quality i got one of the
helix sleep mattresses i think it's
[ __ ] phenomenal i don't even feel my
wife getting out of bed that's
tremendous
so this is why everyone from gq to
forbes is talking about helix sleep so
do me a favor go to helixleep.com right
now slash joey j-o-e-y and get 50 off
your order again go to helixsleep.com
joey and get 50 off your order that's
helixsleep.com
joey j-o-e-y
and get 50
off your order how's that one for you
wow that was a good read you know i
don't [ __ ] around people i'm trying to
make the best of what i got i ain't got
much but what i got i give you my
[ __ ] heart all right
let me talk to you people about
something
uh i got a call from an agency they
asked me if i want to look at something
i took a look at it
the holidays are coming
i'm trying to give you guys a good deal
all right
the product came we looked it over
lee liked it
and there you go all right
that's all that matters we look at the
product we use it we'll see how it feels
lee looks happy with it it's the black
with the red in the middle what i'm
talking about is mvmt watches all right
you want to know where you purchase it
this is the whole deal with these guys
good looking watch yeah it is
you know
the company was started by two broke
college kids that wanted to wear stylish
watches but couldn't afford them plain
and simple they started their own watch
company you know how they did it they
started from scratch they did podcasts
they did youtube they did radio and they
got the word out movement watches start
at 95
at a department store you're looking at
a four to five hundred dollars movement
figured out that by selling online they
were able to cut out the middleman and
the retail market providing you with the
best possible price it's classic design
quality construction and style
minimalism over half a million watches
have been sold in 160 countries this is
what i'm doing for you tonight it's the
holidays all right this listen they
start at 95 hours this is what you get
you never know when people come over
they're feeling gloomy you give them a
watch you make that [ __ ] day what it
costs your yardstick what do you give a
[ __ ]
put it on the visa card that's right
right now today i'm gonna give you 15
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to mvmtwatches.com
church again 15 off today free shipping
free returns by going mvmt
com slash church all right
listen this watch is tremendous
lee's been getting compliments from
freaks everybody likes his watch now is
the time to step up your watch game you
don't want to go to new year's party
with some [ __ ] timex looking like
harvey to [ __ ] you know go to mvmt
right now i'm gonna give you 15 off
today with free shipping and free
returns
go to mvmtwatches.com
church how's that one for you
[ __ ]
man i wish i was an advertiser on this
show because you take it and you bring
it to a whole other level
what do you want me to do i got to put
some heart into these [ __ ] if i
like the product i want them to feel at
home if not i don't want to [ __ ] pimp
this [ __ ] out why why would i do
something like that i'm the last of the
real mccoy you know right
who you could i'd sell you for [ __ ]
fifty dollars
hold on one second i just want to talk
to you people here from the heart
all right
you know me guys i'm a man on the
[ __ ] go
i'm always trying to make it happen
i try to watch shows okay
a friend of mine told me to watch a show
named take my wife
on seesaw i started watching my wife you
know what it makes me giggle i love it
but most importantly
uh
my special's gonna be on it
now
lee likes it please watch c so i think
he watches to sign that lives on there
he said
but uh
i gotta tell you guys something
what's the best thing you've bought for
3.99 lately
well for cso it's 399 a month and ceso
has nearly endless supplies of top shelf
comedy [ __ ] literally months worth of
executive originals face melting stand
up and next day late night and great
catalog of classics that's why my
special is going to be on seesaw we all
have your own unique taste you know what
i'm saying they got they got they got
what are we talking about here they got
snl they got they got british late night
talk show they got
with cso it's your comedy you get comedy
the way you want it all right cso is the
place for comedy they won't tell you how
amazing they are but i will ceso is
amazing and it's for comedy nerds comedy
nerds like lisa
last night not last night i'm not gonna
[ __ ] you people two nights ago i
watched harmon quest all right and you
know what it was pretty funny it's an
original comedy so you want see so
here's what i'm going to do for you my
special comes out december 8th what is
it today november 11th november 14th
it's going to be the 15th do me a favor
see so it's spelled s-e-e-s-o
all right what i want you to do is they
got every episode in snl including the
day after so they got the tonight show
starring jimmy fallon they got seth
meyers they got 30 rock they got parks
and rec they got saved by the bell they
got british comedies the office of ricky
gervais they got monty python listen do
me a favor
i don't care what you do do this for me
personally right now to all you guys i'm
going to give you two free months of cso
when you use promo code joey at checkout
all right shows you can't get nowhere
else just go to cso
seso.com right now and sign up for two
months free with promo code joey and
check out that cso.com promo code joey
the best thing is we get to hang out
together the month of december you can
play this special for your [ __ ]
uncles all right knock yourself out have
a great night i want to thank cso i want
to thank helix sleep i want to thank
mbmt watchers and i want to thank and as
always go to honda.com and get 10
percent off on it
church boom church
and you're getting 10 off again stocking
stuffers [ __ ] i'm looking out for you
i'll see you wednesday night 8 o'clock
be there or go [ __ ] shoot yourself
all right not to mention don't forget my
main man breakfast simmons at flappers
what time
november 17th probably eight o'clock
that's thursday night eight o'clock go
to flappers.com right now they either
got burbank or claremont you want to go
to bed back they got [ __ ] beanies
brewery uh well they got bonnie's [ __ ]
barney's beanie down the block you go in
there you watch a game and then you go
see my man [ __ ] greg i'm setting up
the night for you and then if you smoke
a joint before greg at flatbush you get
a nice order of wings and get the nice
cheese plate one thing about flappers is
they got great food you get a little
high and you watch greg fitzsimmons
who's better than you i love it me i'm
at the come and get a festival
friday night
10 o'clock show the tickets to 35 hours
for the all-day festival
come to what's the name of the website
here what the [ __ ] come and get it
listen google come and take it dot com
festival
and the date will come up and you buy
the one day pass for friday it's 35
bucks all right number two i got the
improv in uh irvine the night before
thanksgiving the 23rd 8 o'clock show
i'll get you out of there by 10 30. you
go to your bars to see your buddies from
college and snort blow and get ready for
turkey all right i love it i love you
guys one more time greg fitzsimmons one
more time on man lisa uncle joey loves
you [ __ ] with all my heart stay
black see you wednesday
[Music]
she's
[Music]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
baby
[Music]
watching
[Music]
there was
[Music]
don't you think
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
that's all
[Music]
right now baby
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
hey